hey man it's me kevin smith look at me
my funny goofy hat don't i look like
hella from thor don't you sometimes just
want to club that kevin smith well how
about instead you join that kevin smith
club oh my god we've been having such a
good time we have hours of audio kids in
the smodcast podcast archives that you
can stick into your ear holes and listen
to or do you want to look at something
are you one of them dirty cucks well
then go to the smithsonian screening
room where you can watch hundreds of
hours of video of my entire career
spanning from the beginning up until now
including my daily morning show wake and
bake man will we just smoke weed hang
out and i tell you what i'm working on
plus there's exclusive events we've had
clerks 3 screenings for our club members
we've had smod castle exclusive shows
for our members back in jersey we do
events all the time including movies
pop-ups and there's tons of merchandise
of course that that kevin smith club
members get exclusive access to before
anybody else there are so many ways into
that kevin smith club ladies and
gentlemen you don't have to come through
the front door you can come through the
back door we like it that way sign up as
a clerk where you get access to all the
audio that we got or join as a mall rep
that gives you all the audio and all the
video as well or join as a fun employee
ladies and gentlemen you'll get a new
t-shirt an exclusive that kevin smith
club t-shirt every quarter or join as a
yoga hoser and get yourself something
cool like that kevin smith wake and bake
bowl ladies and gentlemen those are our
existing levels but what about the new
levels that's right for 2022 we've added
some levels including the fashionable
mail you get everything that the clerk
the mall rat the yoga hoser and the fun
employee gets but you also get once a
year an exclusive piece of wardrobe from
a kevin smith film straight out the
viewers universe from the secret stash
archives or join as a brand new ranger
danger man that gives you everything
that the clerk the mall rep the fun
employee and the yoga hoser gets as well
as what the fashionable male gets but
then you also once a year get an
exclusive prop direct from one of my
movies and if you've got untold riches
coming out of your ass guess what holy
cow there's the golden calves level man
for that level you come to my house i
cook you dinner we record a podcast and
we shoot it for wake and bacon it goes
up on spodcast man very exclusive once a
year we do that join us at
thatkevinsmithclub.com be a clerk be a
mall rep be a fun employee be a yogas or
be a fashionable male be a ranger danger
or be a golden calf ladies and gentlemen
i'll be waking and baking for you come
join me at that kevin smith club
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i know you're real
[Applause]
uh welcome back captain how are you i'm
good man how are you so good uh my mom
was gonna be here tonight but she i was
like oh there's like 60 70 people there
she was like
um okay should i wear a mask and then
suddenly i got scared because i my mom's
been visiting me for like a week and a
half and i've kept her so [ __ ]
safe like my house is a [ __ ] death
trap for a 76 year old woman everything
is like tile and [ __ ] so if you go down
you go down hard and so i've been trying
to like protect her and she's like it
reminds me honestly it's so [ __ ] up
the last way i felt this way about
somebody in my house was when stan lee
came to visit
and he was [ __ ] 92 at that point so i
was like watch you watch where you're
going dude look don't turn around and
talk to me walk down the stairs we'll
talk at the bottom of the [ __ ] stairs
and [ __ ] pay attention what you're doing
same [ __ ] thing with my mother man
it's been like taking care of a
puppy made of faberge eggs like and
so the idea of like getting to the
[ __ ] goal post and then suddenly she
gets coveted was like
i just wasn't gonna chance it and stuff
so she says hello to everybody but what
a [ __ ] i'll tell her when i get home
but uh
what a wonderful trip it's been
absolutely um she i took her to see
elvis our good friend brett deacon who
works at 40x and and screenx that's how
we get all those sweet tickets to give
away and [ __ ]
uh he arranged a screenx screening
of the elvis movie baslerman's elvis
movie and my mom as if you might
remember i took her to graceland because
that was her
[ __ ] mecca and [ __ ] like that and so
we you know when i said while you're out
here
i i think i could set up a screening of
the movie before it comes out and she
was like oh my god i would love that so
we got to go the screen their place is
not really far from my house and [ __ ]
and two and a half hours this movie is
spellbinding particularly in the screen
x presentation catch it if you can in
that version it's it's not just the
front wall it comes to life on three
walls and so all the performance footage
is like you're surrounded by it
um
my mom three times
cried like during the movie and it was
so [ __ ] weird because like in the
movie i'm sure if you've seen the
trailer there's a scene where like he
[ __ ] like wiggles his pelvis for the
first time and all the women are like ah
you see women get moist like in
in the crowd and they play it up and
[ __ ] like big time and so um after that
like the indication like you know elvis
mom is like they want to hurt him and
his dad's like hurt him they want to
[ __ ] him they didn't say [ __ ] him but
like they stop him from saying [ __ ] is a
pg-13 movie or something you know they
get one they don't waste the time
they're not gonna waste it there
whatsoever so um it you know it was
it my mom was like crying at that scene
because she was like i was that was
before i was even with your father like
i remember that but she was she made it
clear she was like but i
didn't i never looked at his pants like
that
like she didn't want to be lumped in
with the movie where all the girls were
like looking at his [ __ ] and [ __ ] like
that and and she was like that was it
wasn't about the [ __ ] for me you know
i was like [ __ ]
she was dick printing elvis oh my god
absolutely it might have been her first
exposure to a [ __ ] jiggling [ __ ] and
um
the movie is like wonderful i don't know
how to fit somebody's giant life in the
[ __ ] two and a half hours baslerman
did a great job doing it
um austin butler
uh was absolutely [ __ ] elvis like
just became the guy even [ __ ] fat
elvis they put him in the makeup and
[ __ ] and like really thin people and fat
makeup it just don't work he they
they've spent some money this movie mark
is so expensive like [ __ ] they must
have spent
100 200 million bucks maybe easily 200
million because they recreate like 1950
every outfit they do a crowd full of
people you got 400 people every extra
has their hair done and they're wearing
[ __ ] period clothing and [ __ ] just so
[ __ ] god god awful expensive but put
to wonderful use because it really did
[ __ ] recreate the error it's a
majesty a marvel of [ __ ] cinema
of motion picture uh cinema
but watching my mom cry during it was
realizing like you know she's my mom
she's 76 and [ __ ] but at one point she
was like a total fan girl and like you
know you would think like you know all
these stories she didn't care she the
whole time she's telling me through the
movie she's like oh colonel tom parker
was so damn good and she'll like that
like and this movie's showing us that
i'm like mom i'm pretty [ __ ] sure
that's what they're implying here and
she's like yeah he was a bastard and
[ __ ]
so at the end of the movie she was like
crying and she was like oh my god and
that boy he was so wonderful she loved
the movie she was like that boy she goes
i want to meet that boy that beautiful
boy who played elvis and i was like you
have met that boy ma like he was in
yoga hosers he played one of the satanic
teens and [ __ ]
and my mother without missing a beach
he's just like oh
well this movie will be way better for
his career
[Laughter]
that was a good point good point um it
was [ __ ] sweet her i'm telling you
like it's been a wonderful visit but
like the weirdest things
are doing it for her i guess like this
is gonna sound like a commercial for hbo
max and it's not
but holy [ __ ] my mother discovered the
magic of hbo max like when she first got
here you know i i had to put something
on to you for her to go to sleep to and
i was like oh watch hacks with jean
smart like it's [ __ ] amazing you'll
think it's funny and stuff like that
she's like 70 and stuff
so
my mom was like watching hacks and she
kept falling asleep it took her like
four days to watch it it kept running
all the way through and she was like
waking up in season two and [ __ ] like
that
now she's like i see there are other
things and i was like yeah she's like
father of the bride
and i was like okay and so she's
watching the new father the bride
[ __ ] movie and [ __ ]
she's learned to control it you know
it's a [ __ ] laptop so it's her mind
yes she's like [ __ ] give me the
goddamn mom entertainment i couldn't get
her to the hallmark channel i felt like
a real [ __ ] failure and [ __ ] that's
why i brought her to hbo max but
this morning i [ __ ] got up and like
you know i went to bed at like 10
uh we had a big day so you know she was
like watching [ __ ] father of the
bride and i figure like it ended she
would close the laptop go to sleep but
my mom's a real night owl she was up all
night [ __ ] watching movies she was
like oh do you notice hbo max has so
many movies and i was like you sound
like a [ __ ] commercial right now she
was like i watched monster in law
and i was like you watched like a decade
old movie and [ __ ]
and she's like i ever saw jane fonda and
j lo always so funny and she's like and
then what would she watch she's like sit
down with me watch this she's like it's
about a a night and he falls in love and
he's trapped in time my mother was
[ __ ] watching kate and leopold man
like
this old ass move i was like mom they
made that when i worked at miramax she's
like oh it's wonderful you have to make
ryan's in it look at her hair and i was
like i did in the year 2000 when they
made the [ __ ] motion picture does hbo
max have like a mom channel that just
literally pulls you in this loop
of non-offensive old [ __ ] i think i
think once you go from like you know
[ __ ] father of the bride they're like
all right well what's close to that and
they're like kate and leopold
um tiger i just watched this show
euphoria
you should watch this with me that would
be amazing that's what i'm gonna do
tonight i'm gonna be like ma here's a
brand new show for you to watch it's
called euphoria kids love it
see if you can make heads or tails of it
can we get some fentanyl it'd be amazing
because i come down every morning like
when i wake up and [ __ ] and sometimes
she's awake sometimes she's [ __ ] out
cold
and you know i look real close make sure
she's breathing and then i run upstairs
and i get her tea and whatnot and so
she'll tell me what she [ __ ] wants
she tells me like what she's watching
while it's happening and then like she
watched clerk's three she started
telling me the story i'm like i [ __ ]
know man like
so i would love to like just be like uh
i'm gonna run this euphoria for you i
hear it's very good
and hit play and just go away for
[ __ ] six hours and see if i come back
in the morning and she's like these kids
are [ __ ] up
um but it's been delightful really
delightful having her around but
nerve-wracking because i'm always like
dude don't move don't move it's weird
it's like life-free verses that's how
she treated me when i was a kid and now
that's how i treat her when she's it
makes more sense for me to treat her
like this because she's like [ __ ]
brittle and [ __ ] one fallen it's like
you know she could lose a hip or
whatever but you know
it's the turnaround is the turnabout has
certainly been noticed she's brought it
up a few times she was like i used to
baby you like you baby me i was like i'm
not babying you i'm just trying to make
sure that like when i send you back to
my brother donald like you're not
damaged and he's like you [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ]
you know this is what [ __ ] uncle andy
did to grab my you know family history
having thrown in your face i just you
know it's been
impeccable visits so far i just got to
make it
another like we leave at noon tomorrow
what time is it right now
whatever the [ __ ] yes 12 15 hours to get
her onto that [ __ ] plane then i gotta
sweat the plane don't [ __ ] go down
otherwise i'll get blamed for that [ __ ]
as well somehow then once she's landed
in my brother's car then i'll be like ah
i can relax my [ __ ]
i can unclench it'll
that sounded weird it was like once my
mom leaves my [ __ ] will be [ __ ]
unoccupied no
just i've been clenched the whole
[ __ ] time man going like don't don't
move sit don't
so many don'ts your watch will have
ended
and you can go back to just living a
life in [ __ ] westeros man that's true
is that what they did at the end i
thought they all [ __ ] died and that
was that well i mean some people died
but not everybody no like when you were
on the night's watch well you have to
die to get off the night's watch right
so i don't want that but jon snow
for you guys who might have forgotten
died once in the show and then gets
resurrected and he's like [ __ ] it i died
i gave you the thing here's my token i'm
bouncing
like you can't leave joan snow he's like
i know something
he doesn't
we'll talk more about jon snow later
because jon snow is back in the news
oh my god they put a picture up bless
you that was fast somebody that was
andrew andrew was there for elvis as
well andrew do you like elvis
he loved it
put that on a [ __ ] poster
sell some tickets you should hear my mom
she's like she loved it so much she was
box office prognosticating she's like oh
i was gonna make way more money than
that top gun i was like no it ain't mom
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about like but you're very sweet
um but it should do some [ __ ]
business it better [ __ ] my god it looks
expensive
i i mean like
i wonder
if a movie costs 200 million bucks and a
shoot is say
four months what do you think the cost
per day of the movie is somebody good at
math yeah i'm not
well i heard somebody go uh like they
were literally thinking it's like long
division and i'm not down for that some
people are like real good like that and
[ __ ] yeah i'm not one of them
apparently yeah this was fun
they're [ __ ]
stumped by men right off yeah maths
involved [ __ ] everybody's like we're
drunk what the [ __ ]
um regardless i wonder like what the
cost is per day on a movie like that
it's got to be huge and they had to shut
down remember because tom hanks was like
right the first celebrity to get covet
at that time that's when they were
making that movie the hanks wilson line
had been crossed and suddenly everybody
gave a [ __ ] um
how are you never mind [ __ ] me and my
nonsense what are you i'm good
i also saw a long expensive movie
i saw a movie called
rrr do you guys know about this movie
yes no yes
it's [ __ ] bonkers man it's a it's an
indian film
there's a poster for it that's up right
now oh yeah yeah that [ __ ] thing
third most expensive movie ever made in
india
it's three hours long holy [ __ ]
it's both
a somewhat accurate retelling of two
literal people who lived in india during
the 1920s
pre the rebellion against britain and
it's also this [ __ ] weird ass magical
realist fantasy and a martial arts movie
and a dance movie
and an action movie and a like deep bond
of brothers movie pick a [ __ ] lane
man no
every [ __ ] lane this movie's charged
every movie they're like what if we made
every movie at once yeah
and like every time i think i know what
this movie is going to do it does
something completely differently it's on
netflix now
um
and listen you will not spend a better
three hours if you're not an elvis
apparently
but watch this [ __ ] movie like
i
what does the rrr mean
to short for something is abbreviation
well
like they they have these little
subtitles over the course of the movie
these chapter titles yes and so it's
like either rage and roar and rebellion
or it's these two dudes names and then a
third person who i don't know
um
or it's just her
it's all unclear it's like a growl of
joy
um but no it's it's fantastic it's it's
it's hard to that's the problem is like
they don't say the name of the movie in
trailers anymore like in the 80s it was
always just like you know angel hooker
by day
no [ __ ] student by day hook her by
night
poker by day
hello
people like it's a little early don't
you think angel
um but they would always say the movie
talent like the [ __ ] trailer for the
empire strikes back literally says the
empire strikes back because like the
[ __ ] trailer for jobs is [ __ ]
percy rodriguez the greatest trailer
voiceover artist of all time going jaws
you know but nowadays they don't [ __ ]
say the trailer whatsoever so you don't
know how to say rrr you could be right
could be earned [ __ ]
you know what else we're missing these
days you know who to settle this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you could do that [ __ ]
mr movie phone ah
remember you call up you'd be like [ __ ]
rated r
showtimes are one o'clock
that dude was a [ __ ] king and now
nobody talks about him anymore because
the internet
i bet you he's like living in his
penthouse like the legend just angry
that the world has passed him by
let me tell you what i used to do i was
banging cocktail waitresses three at a
time when my voice meant something
when i was the voice of cinema [ __ ] man
i know how he feels
1.6 per day thank you for doing the math
one point and you know appreciated that
1.6 million a day that's a lot of money
[ __ ]
you could make
so many little movies
[Music]
that was the point of all that that's
why i needed all that math
how many so many [ __ ] movies you
could make like 80 little moves
um what else did you do besides watch tv
um uh well
what else am i supposed to do i know
that sounded very dismissive i didn't
mean it like that
well like leave the house no [ __ ] you
um i've been writing
a lot i'm i'm on the show that i'm
working on that i still can't talk about
because that's you know come on
um what the [ __ ] secret squirrel why
can't you tell us because for all the
reasons i can never tell just test the
[ __ ] theory man test the waters and
be like here it is blah put it out there
and [ __ ] no
[Laughter]
come on do it for a free podcast want to
be great just so i can burn everything
down and see what happens
i do that every few years with my career
it's healthy
a forest needs a fire sometimes yeah
sometimes you just gotta [ __ ] raise
the earth is it going too well for you
chant exactly like some [ __ ] on fire
sometimes you just gotta make yoga
hosers
it's my second yogozi's joke of the
night if i make a third one i would have
said of steak knives
uh so yes i've been writing
pretty
heavily last couple of weeks took a
break to come here tonight and play with
you um watching the tv that i'm supposed
to watch
because we have [ __ ] we need to talk
about
um so i'm now caught up on the boys yeah
well let me tell you something
i
i can't tell you much about the boys but
i'll be able to tell you a whole [ __ ]
bunch of [ __ ] about kate and leopold
i can't wait to watch the boys and once
my mom is safely ensconced on the planet
should maybe all relax and watch how
many episodes are the boys five oh
that's gonna be amazing that's like a
day of the boys man that's something to
do by myself because i asked my wife and
she was like she was like i watched
season three with you i was like you
can't watch season three
unless you watch season one or two she's
like i don't want to do that
and i was like why are you [ __ ]
breaking the rules and [ __ ] man and then
i'm gonna have to pause it and explain
every [ __ ] thing she's like i'm only
gonna half watch it and i was like well
then don't [ __ ] watch it at all
so i'll watch it by myself this is my
thing now yeah [ __ ]
uh but yeah the boys is [ __ ] great
episode five was good it's it seems to
be taking a little bit of a break before
apparently what we're getting is
herogasm
yeah where everybody [ __ ] everybody i
think
near as i can tell that's what we're
lining up for that's on the runway
is the biggest superhero orgy anybody's
ever seen which
is not hard to accomplish because i've
never seen one
um
i don't watch that kind of porn
that's not your category i'm pouring out
my bag baby
um
what is your category on pornhub
now that we're there what's the one you
were there what's the one that you
gravitate toward um
i like road stops
you know like
i i don't know if i'm familiar with that
category what is that it's one of those
my car's busted
can somebody fix my car
yeah
[Music]
that has its own category bro
everything has its own apparently holy
[ __ ] so wait it's like so leo porno was
like pizza man
this porno is i'm stuck it's triple a
basically and triple a shows up
yeah but sometimes it's true with the
right tool sometimes it's triple d
oh [ __ ]
a what meaning vice versa like guys
break down and a lady shows up because
that would be a quality or more than one
[Music]
and but they all [ __ ] in the street
where is this happening where are these
cars pulled over
why don't we do it in the road
look i have seen people [ __ ] the
street my point is not enough
so i'm like where is this happening in
is it off off road like it's usually
like off the highway usually it starts
in the highway and then [ __ ] moves into
like a picnic setting or oh my god they
have to move
i mean yeah could you imagine if you had
to move like you started [ __ ] in one
place and your wife was like let's move
company move i mean maybe people do that
maybe but maybe there's a lot of silence
there because people like i always [ __ ]
it more i pick her up and i go over here
and [ __ ] and that makes me feel so
[ __ ] lazy right now
maybe i should up my game [ __ ] i'm 51
and i'm only realizing this now god damn
it
and how am i supposed to do that with my
mother in the house mark
i i enjoyed this roller coaster cam yeah
narrative i'm back
um
so what the how did we uh oh superhero
orgy no [ __ ] back to the road porn
that you like
[Music]
why is that based on like one time your
car broke down or some sort of [ __ ] i
mean i thought lots of cars break down
and it's never happened but
oh my god
maybe you just drive the cars you don't
get them fixed because you're like if it
breaks down it could happen yeah
and so i've left 19 cars on the side of
the road
so are these these sound like they're
pre-produced porn so it's like make
pretend and [ __ ] like that i like real
[ __ ] i love like just real [ __ ] when
they're like we're a couple and we just
film ourselves [ __ ] i'm like god damn
it
that's america man like [ __ ] could
you imagine having that kind of pride
where you're like we're gonna [ __ ] each
other and we're gonna let you watch that
is nuts man well you're you're an indie
filmmaker so i see how that it's
true come too i'm like [ __ ] that's
cheaper than clerks look at that and way
more entertaining and funnier look at
that [ __ ] dick it's you like your diy
spirit kids yeah
um all right so back to what we were
talking about
um
yes the boys
i'm about halfway through stranger
things
this most recent season have you watched
any of it i st
don't make me say it what nobody's going
to treat me seriously on the show
everybody's going to say you've never
watched drinks i just never watched
stranger things yet so i've yet to watch
look
i'm gonna get to it it's not because i'm
like i'm [ __ ] angry at this show
um i don't know who gave me this but
this does not work so if you want to
make it work is this yours
well then
make it work
make it work
you better work um i will get around to
watching that for sure no you won't
i will i've got so many episodes i get
how many seasons i got this is the
fourth season jesus really four already
four already um yeah man that'll be how
many episodes per season uh
usually between eight and ten i'll be
like i'll be a weekend one day man i'll
be like let's watch stranger things we
almost did a couple weeks ago and then
we started gaslight instead
with uh see i i think that's poor i
wouldn't do it with the white uh you
know what should i redo it with the
silver
where was the silver that i just had
i don't know [ __ ]
hold on one second we got a show to do
hi kids
yeah [ __ ] it sorry
whenever the part of the benefit of
coming to the live show is that people
bring [ __ ] put it on the bar obviously
if you've seen us through many episodes
sit around
and and sign [ __ ] um but every once in a
while somebody hands you the driest ass
marker right so we're trying this one
you have to do it do small
do it slowly
ooh new marker
oh that's pretty
you guys can't see this at home but
that's a really good build i'm saying
right like look you can see it from home
[ __ ] it's that bright [ __ ] them white
markers man
yeah this is being happy juneteenth on
this
this is what
um all right back to you
nothing i'm just inciting a race riot
don't mind me
like you do
on a tuesday in hollywood
um
all right so i talked about the crazy
indian film that i saw rrr
do you want to talk about kenobi which
you're finally caught up with
um yeah let's do that i finally watched
was how many episodes are up five so
there's only one left correct yes
[ __ ] i thought you were gonna keep
talking i was gonna sign but i saw you
reach for your drink and i'm like we're
both gonna be silent
it's okay go take your drink
you're still being i'm only silent when
i get paid to be silent
um all right take over kenobi episode
five guys
dude i talked about it for an hour last
week when you asked me man just say some
[ __ ] so i can sign this
did you like it
oh god damn it say some [ __ ] until i
sign this
no
cause i don't wanna bro the difficulty
of signing a piece of clothing is like
[ __ ] right up there with running a
marathon the difficulty of signing a
[ __ ] jersey with a paint pen marker
and [ __ ]
exponentially increases take over the
show for a few minutes
this is gonna take everything i have
it's like i've been fasting for three
days
and i gotta sign this shirt all right
listen here's here's here's my my
but see
now i feel like bamf oh
[ __ ] thank god give it up for banff
man everybody
[Applause]
this [ __ ] fumbling fool over here
letting the show die go ahead batman
what do you got um mark do you
do you think because you are
yeah a little less
show back to mark man
you're supposed to [ __ ] save it
little lukewarm on the show do you think
they turn it around tonight
um here's here's i've been thinking
about this uh the last couple of weeks
and the thing that i've
discovered about how i feel about the
show is that i'm unclear
what the obi-wan story they're telling
is
because when we first meet ewan
mcgregor's obi-wan kenobi in episode one
he's a broken ass man
you know his ultimate he's essentially
the same guy we meet
maybe a little bit more grim than alec
guinnesses obi-wan kenobi in a new hope
but in basically the same place like i
don't give a [ __ ] about anything i'm
here on this rock just kind of maybe
watching this kid cutting meat
cutting [ __ ] meat like making spay
sushi oh that's his job right he's just
like
don't know jedi's here i'm just a
butcher do you think he goes like
back in the day i had a tool called a
lightsaber it would have cut this meat
so much easier than this knife
hell yeah
but so just i'm trying to also when they
cook the meat he's like back in the day
i watched that happen on my [ __ ]
sorry sorry go ahead
i wanted you to talk i gave it a whole
[ __ ] floor and you're like i'm gonna
hum in a humming hum and then this
[ __ ] had to come in and save the
day and now you want to talk take it now
i don't want it no
no listen i'm trying to figure out what
obi-wan kenobi's arc is like where he's
starting where he's evolving to and
where he's going yes and it doesn't seem
as if there's very much for him to go
because he starts [ __ ] grim and
dispirited yeah he encounters young
[ __ ] princess leia
does some weird ass
precocious kid [ __ ]
maybe gets involved with vader again who
he cannot
kill he leia cannot die and he cannot
die so it's a bunch of like just moving
duck chairs that's why it's like anybody
who wasn't in star wars
probably going to get killed along all
of you red shirts no just wearing red
the lady the imperial officer i was like
she ain't gonna make it and sure enough
spoilers she didn't make it i'm waiting
for [ __ ] ice cube to be like today
was not a good day
yes
he might be next yeah man it's true it's
like rogue one you're like none of these
[ __ ] are gonna make it man i saw the
next movie
yeah so like i just kept on wondering
and especially like i
i really like what they're doing with
riva i just don't like how they're doing
it with rifa what do you mean why in
that
uh okay this is a little bit of an
insidery screenwriting thing but there's
there's a storytelling mode that's
called cards up and there's one called
cards down cards down is when you don't
know anything about the character and
some any information you get about that
person is reveal
cards up is you know everything you need
to know about that character they tell
you what you need to know about their
character and things can happen that are
surprising but she herself is not a
mystery
and so
i'm just wondering how much more solid
the revelation in episode five would
have been
that she's hunting vader if we didn't
also have to absorb the knowledge that
she was a young lady which we had all
kind of assumed she was but she actually
comes out and says it but if you start
the show with
i was a youngling and i then turned to
the dark side because the jedi didn't
give a [ __ ] about me it's like oh all
right i get that's why you're evil 100
i got it you don't like jedi's because
they [ __ ] didn't save you when you
needed to be saved and then the twist
being oh no i'm really in this to kill
[ __ ] vader i've been doing all this
[ __ ] i'm undercover i've been just
trying to get next to this fool so i can
[ __ ] the only problem with that is
the whole premise of the first half is i
hate jedi's because blah blah blah and
then vader would be like oh you were one
of the younglings i didn't finish the
job on come here and he kills her so she
has to be undercover well she can be i'm
the cards up is to the audience the
audience can know this she can betray
this in episode three when she's looking
at this tunnel and mystically discovers
what it's supposed to mean as opposed to
oh i took this tunnel this was my
journey right which again we all sort of
intuited this as people who like watch
stories but to have her have some
engagement with that part of her past
that the audience gets to see but the
the characters don't just helps us know
who she is helps us know what her
struggle is and helps us think we know
what she's going to do so when she
twists it that's the twist not oh here's
new information he didn't have before
like oh okay she's that oh but she wants
to kill vader why couldn't she kill him
any other she's like standing next to
that dude like four times in the show
with a lightsaber on her you why okay i
guess now's the time well i mean she did
try to attack him and he was like
you know like he has spoilers like
spoilers he is you know he is darth
vader yeah i get it
um this is the thing that i was [ __ ]
like impressed by and i don't know if
this is something to be impressed by
maybe people be like no
this removes the majesty of [ __ ] star
wars most people think of star wars as
movies
star wars is now a series of television
shows and you know with the mandalorian
you're not thinking about it so much
because hey he wasn't even in any of the
star wars movies he's connected to the
universe but he's not you know [ __ ]
classic star wars
you know when you're playing with
obi-wan kenobi
young princess leia
darth vader you are playing with legacy
star wars characters who have loomed
large those three characters were in the
very first [ __ ] one dating back to 77
and [ __ ] the idea that we now live in a
world where
they structured this
last episode
with
vader flashing back
and ben kenobi flashing back something
that you've seen a gazillion times in tv
shows across [ __ ] broadcasting
history
and now they get to do it with star wars
we had a [ __ ] vader flashback has
that ever [ __ ] happened in a star
wars anything ever have you ever gone
into vader's mind we watched him [ __ ]
look out the window for years whenever
he was pensive he was just looking out
into [ __ ] space
now he's doing the same thing but we get
to see what he's thinking about and
apparently all he thinks about is i
[ __ ] hate ben kenobi
oh god i still [ __ ] ate him with a
dick i was burning and he left me like a
[ __ ] hot dog
and also that he was just cucking out on
padme because that's the building he's
staring at when he's on coruscant is the
like the high rise that padme is in
because it's probably beginning of
attack of the clones it's kind of that
timeline
when is vader when no when he's anakin
right before most of the staring i'm
talking about is all the vader but
that's just what he does he starts out
into the distance my point is now
we get to watch but now we well that's
the thing here's and here's the question
yeah because you're a [ __ ] writer
um some so am i sometimes but like
is it
bet like you know what it's not about
better or worse
we came from a world
where it's like you said he's looking
out there you cast on to him hungering
like for food yeah he's just like i want
a burger
where's the next [ __ ] stop but like
the idea that he wants more never once
and all the time i've watched star wars
did i think this [ __ ] is
hungering for [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
in my imagination he looks out into
space
and he's just like i hate all these
[ __ ] fools
that's [ __ ] darth vader to me
now we literally know
what he thinks about when he looks into
space because they've shown us something
they never would have done never have
done and never would have done
in a feature because you ain't got that
kind of time in the future you got two
hours two and a half you got some [ __ ]
to do man
this is like we got six hours or
whatever the [ __ ] we get six episodes we
can
space it out we could do storytelling of
different forms shapes and forms per
episode so i personally enjoyed it that
i was like oh my god they treated darth
vader
and ben kenobi like they would have
treated [ __ ] sydney bristow and alias
and her dad or whatever the [ __ ] like
it's a trope a writing trope like i've
seen it time and time again doesn't mean
it's bad
like just like good guys and bad guys
are writing trope that's not bad
but we've never seen it in the star wars
universe at least with these big
characters i'm sure somebody's like hey
man in the [ __ ] clone wars episode
blah blah blah i'm sure but with [ __ ]
luke's with uh ben kenobi darth vader
darth vader himself particularly
seeing that dude and then having them do
a close-up and then go to a flashback is
classic television storytelling where
you're like now we're inside the
character's mind and they have never
done that with darth vader's my question
to you
is
do you i'm not saying better or worse do
you prefer
the mystery
vader from the movies
or
do you
accept prefer whatever the [ __ ]
a vader who we look inside of whose
memories whose feelings
we're getting to see and and now don't
come at me with like hey man we heard
his feelings when he was dying and re
turning the jedi and [ __ ] like that no
this ain't that like this isn't dude
inside his head they've never done this
correct me for mom vamp man jump in
before mark answers have they ever done
this in a star wars thing uh people in
chat are saying they did it in comic
books yeah of course absolutely but
that's not the [ __ ] conversation
we're having now isn't it
but they've done a lot of [ __ ] things
in comic books no in movies in all the
movies we haven't seen it before
the thing that i was going to talk about
was and it's it's like a three panel
comic book story
and it takes place in the empire to
expect timeline and it's vader going to
to the [ __ ]
whoever the [ __ ] was i don't remember
but the people who dismantled c-3po
and they're like well you know lord
vader we we found this this droid that
you know clearly belonged to
han solo yes
and then you see this shot of of vader
picking up c3bo's head a drawing a
drawing yes but the idea that
he built that [ __ ] droid
like he did that and he remembers this
yes and there is still some attachment
that he has to it decides not to have to
it yes and then the other response the
the third panel is like
burn it or incinerate it
fan made right no i don't think so
that was dark horse that was done
how many times cannon how many times
have you guys seen empire strikes back
how many times what a great [ __ ]
question how many times have i seen
empire 100
no i'm not a [ __ ] nerd um
i probably across my lifetime i would
have seen it at least 100 times okay so
when they're in the carbon freezing
chamber and chewbacca goes nuts
boba fett points his rifle at chewbacca
and vader knocks it down why would he
knock it down
c-3po is on chewbacca's back
[ __ ]
oh that's retconned [ __ ] right there
which is fine i'm happy to play that
game but that is not the [ __ ]
intention that irving kirschner or
[ __ ] lawrence kasdan or george lucas
had for that moment in empire but now
that you raised that point
why in that movie never mind is [ __ ]
made up [ __ ] comes years later
why in empire strikes back does he stop
him from firing because he might be
hitting her
he might be hitting han solo he might
give a [ __ ] about chewie and he
certainly don't give a [ __ ] about c-3po
yeah why does he in 1980 i have no idea
but if you watch episode one two three
four five yeah but don't do the order
then you watch that and you're like oh
my god of course you're right excellent
point yes that's one of those fill in
the gap things but so maybe it was maybe
george watched that and goes why did
irving kirschner do this
and then he's like what if vader made
c3po i'm going to write that as a big
plot point
i'll buy that that's kind of i'm i'm
down with that as a secret origin all
i'll say is that i i appreciate
when you get to add
a certain amount of character texture to
these stories and so i dig that sort of
thing it's cool though you get to go in
his head right cool that you get to go
and he said you get access to him
because we've lived with that character
for long enough but i bet you there are
people who would be like i don't want to
be in his [ __ ] head i like him being
a mystery the more we know about that
like there are people that don't like
the prequels because like i didn't want
to know he was a little boy that [ __ ]
like didn't like sand in his underpants
or whatever the [ __ ] like
you know it's like it kind of ruins the
mystery of the character i'm i'm okay
i've been with these movies since the
beginning
they're gonna keep going with them give
me more detail rather than him looking
out a window i thought it was cool that
they were like oh he's thinking about
something and here it is yeah it's like
i need less plot
but i like those little character
moments of now i get to know a thing
about a person
that doesn't contradict what i thought i
knew that doesn't retcon anything but
just as adding more color
to that to that character so i'm totally
cool with that that's fun
nice to see those from the water sorry
yeah
nice to see aiden christensen back in
the ponytail
yeah in the 10th thin-ass ponytail
[ __ ]
lightsaber fight i appreciate that they
didn't go like deep uncanny valley on
the de-aging but that dude does not look
like he's 19 anymore well i mean you
know he is what is he 40 at this he's
41. yeah i i was okay i took the leap on
that one
um
but it was uh you know i it was it was
cool man it was dope i saw a [ __ ]
image online today
of liam neeson lightsaber fighting was
that old or new
probably old because liam neeson's
probably sitting there going i got
stabbed in the gut and only got one
movie and these now two of these [ __ ]
have got stabbed in the gut and they're
both alive
what gives yeah and this girl got
stabbed in a gut twice once as a girl
and now he's an adult and she's just
marching around like nobody's business i
mean it's it's a you'd be crazy to think
that he's not gonna show up in that
final episode if he doesn't show up the
the movie or the miniseries has failed
in my opinion you have to have him come
back
especially when you keep showing ben
kenobi going like quagon are you there
qui-gon can you hear me it's got to be
like
qui-gon who always was like
too
if like in his own head to join the jedi
council too rebellious too rebellious
he's got to show up and be like obi-wan
you were tasked with this thing the jedi
are too dogmatic you changed you know
you were able to pivot you went and
saved the girl you've done the right
thing i'm going to teach you how to be a
blue ghost now
and then you get
that bridge to when he becomes a blue
ghost in empire strikes back um is blue
ghost like a
term of endearment we always say force
ghosts force ghosts are you trying why
are you
stop trying to make blue ghosts happen
you threw me there i was like blue ghost
what the [ __ ]
i smoked that one away um
this is you know i learned a lot of
people online
you know are like hey man folk and
disney keeps ruining star wars i i
disagree more star wars is better than
not more star wars in my book so
obviously i'm happy they keep doing it
and i actually like what they've been
doing
um
i think
it's pretty hardcore
that they stuck with killing the [ __ ]
younglings and hung like a big part of
this whole miniseries on i am literally
a child
that that [ __ ] stabbed to death and i
didn't die but that was his intent and
we all died everyone remember that
everybody [ __ ] died and [ __ ] that's a
big like plot point on a disney plus
tv show i say hats off i know some
people out there like he's [ __ ] paid
to say that i wish i wish disney paid me
nice thing to say nice things about star
wars i wish disney paid me at all that'd
be [ __ ] amazing i just say it because
i mean it i
i i think it's [ __ ] pretty metal man
yeah i mean we talked about this a bit
last week that i do love that they've
stuck to their guns then yeah if you're
going to make him the most evil person
in the galaxy that needs the redemption
the most then you gotta [ __ ] live
with that because i was saying last week
they could have back door
like he didn't kill those kids you know
just when they cut away he was like all
right [ __ ] everyone get out of here
or he was like let's turn him to the
dark side which would be you know just
as [ __ ]
kind of sinister but not as bad as
[ __ ] like oh i cut that kid's [ __ ]
head off with a lightsaber you know
that's what keeps me up at night and
[ __ ] not kate and leopold thinking about
that [ __ ] kid i killed
um so the fact that they didn't is
pretty
yes
well done andrew one
somewhere my mother's getting moist um
the uh the fact that they didn't the
fact that it's pretty hardcores
is something that everyone just kind of
glosses over when they [ __ ] on the show
they're just like oh man
it ain't [ __ ] it's bad star wars i
disagree it's good star wars and more
star wars and again like
[ __ ] my whole life i was like man i
wish we had a darth vader show now we
got it and you know what they're all
talking about how much they love doing
it so there's probably gonna be another
season of this [ __ ] i mean yeah that's
this had been pitched to us as a limited
series and every quote from ian mcgregor
was like i'd do more
like oh [ __ ] it all right let's have
more then
put up her [ __ ] up i'm sure and
christians is like [ __ ] yeah i'll do
more it's the easiest job in the world
man
um
i fall for more
i'd say
to people who look there's some star
wars i really dislike very much yeah
what is it do you
share that or is that something you keep
private yeah i'm the guy who runs common
villains yeah i love all star wars
except for this stuff i don't but the
thing is
the stuff that i
i don't like it's easy to forget because
like wait two minutes right like the
problem with us is and i may have said
this
last show but
we grew up in a time where it was like
well you have six hours of star wars
until
1999 from 1983 and then we got
six more hours of star wars and it was
like now it's gone forever
and then
now we get
six hours of star wars three times a
year
so it's like you don't like kenobi okay
wait for andor you don't like and or
wait for bad batch you don't like bad
batch way for mandalorian like there's
30 hours of live action star wars being
produced
all the time pick your favorite six
hours and forget the rest
and you know who [ __ ] is not speaking
up like people that just love the show
and the numbers seem to support that
people are watching and [ __ ] but like i
you know
i
i haven't heard from anybody in real
life who's like [ __ ] this show it's like
oh my god there's a darth vader show
this rocks nobody expected the princess
leia [ __ ] left turn or anything like
that we all saw the trailer so we
thought all right he's gonna [ __ ]
stare at luke for six episodes and [ __ ]
they actually figured out a way to have
an adventure man like if they want to do
it again i'm all [ __ ] for it just put
the toys back where you found them when
you got started that's all i ask make
sure that all connects so that when we
[ __ ] find him in star wars it's like
yeah that's the same [ __ ] dude
not like where's this robot arm that he
got in season three of obi-wan kenobi
spoilers um
what else have you watched uh you caught
up on ms marvel i am what a charming
[ __ ] show i absolutely love it it's
so
it makes me
like miss being a teenager
um very
whimsical wistful
that kid's a [ __ ] star
um
and it's very you know
i i wasn't crazy familiar with that
character um you know it just plays like
spider-man spider-man origin story not
as dire right there's no like holy [ __ ]
uncle ben got killed
but uh it's
it's the
perfect entry point
for kids to a comic book or in this
instance to a comic book property and
you know so many people
[ __ ] on that because they're like well
it ain't for me and it's like i know but
there was a time where comics were
primarily for who they're going after
with this show
a younger audience and stuff like yeah
everybody can enjoy the avengers and
stuff but you need to hook kids when
they're
[ __ ] young if you want to grow them
up into people that continue liking this
[ __ ] when they get older so much so that
when they have kids they're like oh we
got to watch these marvel things because
i used to watch them with my parents and
stuff
so i i i find it charming as [ __ ] man
like and i think it's
it's exactly right for the audience that
they're
trying to reach and i'm not that
audience but it's working for me
um those directors are incredibly
talented yeah like they just figure out
how to work graphics into everything and
stuff same guy's doing batgirl
um yeah i i absolutely uh dig it um you
know last episode
there wasn't as much
you know super heroics and [ __ ] and even
so
it still carried all the way through i
was never like [ __ ] move on it was
interesting like they're showing me
a world that i'm unfamiliar with um and
and i don't just mean like oh the world
of like a muslim family but like
[ __ ] teenagers today i'm like i don't
i don't have one of those i don't
[ __ ] hang around high schools anymore
and [ __ ] it's been a long time the
restraining order took care of yeah they
were like go away even at degrassi high
so watching this show was a real like
you know insight into oh is that what
kids are like in high school interesting
yeah i've dug it i think it's wonderful
how many episodes is this six or eight i
think it's eight
keep them coming man and uh this is the
character they're bringing into the
cap marvel sequel to marvel the marvels
yeah and i think we also get
monica rambo
or maria i can never remember which
rambo we're getting
um which one was the mom was the mom
maria mama's maria so monica kid is
monica yeah from one division so we get
her in there we get clearly
brie larson and then we're getting
did i dream this or did they announce a
wonderman show they did it is that in
the news yes so we'll get to that i i
didn't know if i was a [ __ ] thing
that i knew or not oh my god how weird
we'll get to that um
yes marvel
ms marvel continues to delight obi-wan
kenobi continues to [ __ ] fascinate
and entertain and thrill the [ __ ]
seven-year-old than me who just wants to
watch [ __ ] a darth vader tv show and
we're getting it i didn't know we were
getting that like i knew he was gonna be
in it and they were like yeah darth
vader's gonna be in i thought they were
gonna save him in the end they'd have
one lightsaber fight we get to spend so
much time in this fucker's head and [ __ ]
see how petty and shitty he is i love
that
um so thumbs up on those [ __ ] shows
yeah i would just like some clarity on
how the force works
because it seems to be working in an
arbitrary and convenient way
which is
there's a i'm gonna start a fire
and that's gonna burn you obi-wan
because i'm a petty [ __ ]
and then i put the fire out of the force
and then somebody lights another fire
and i can't do anything about it
he's like look i can start it i can't
put it out what am i a [ __ ] fireman
and then it's there's a [ __ ]
spaceship that would rip out of the sky
in a completely badass display of power
i saw that and then that's cool but then
i missed the other spaceship that was
right behind it and i can't do it again
yes
it's like oh
[ __ ] i blew my wad i guess i'll just i
gotta power up first um i love not only
that he [ __ ] dragged the ship down
when he tore that [ __ ] open
it was holy [ __ ] man that looks so
[ __ ] badass but
yeah i i thought the
whoa
you know right behind it was a little
[ __ ] hokey but
they could have just had it you know up
in space already they'd taken off
whatever the [ __ ] i don't know but i i
was i was
i liked him ripping open the ship that
was badass that was very good and the
duel with riva is great yeah like that's
some deep force [ __ ] right there which
he probably could have used to keep the
other ship from flying away but
that's neither here nor there
yeah
um all right do we have uh a sponsor
we do speaking of speaking of getting it
up and keeping it up oh yes folks
we don't get to do the show unless
somebody [ __ ] sponsors it and tonight
our sponsor uh as always they've come
back again and again man which means
somebody out there is [ __ ] blue
chewing it man blue chew give it up for
the good folks at blue chew ladies and
gentlemen
they're in the business of keeping you
up literally aren't they mark they are
uh guys it's time to bring that summer
heat into the bedroom mind you i'm
reading their words yes these are not
our words
um we will attempt to put some you don't
call it the summer heat i don't and i
don't say the temperatures aren't the
only thing that's rising this summer
that's right this episode is brought to
you by blue chew guys confidence can
take you far in life it can also help in
the bedroom especially when it comes
time to step up to the plate
that's where blue chew comes in blue
cheese is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
you can take them anytime day or night
so you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises
the process is simple go to
bluetooth.com enter the code fatman at
checkout and just pay five dollars for
shipping that's bluechu.com promo code
fatman to receive your first month for
free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast oh my god we love the folks at
bluechew for sponsoring this podcast and
we love the folks at bluetooth for being
like don't you want to [ __ ] chew this
instead of swallowing it and [ __ ] yeah
more that's what she said
that's brilliant technology and a
brilliant bumper give it up for the good
folks at blue chew our sponsor today
[Applause]
all right we got news i know we got news
we do mr mark bernardin is a man of
letters and he's a man of news he used
to work for the news then he [ __ ]
left he escaped from the newsroom and
[ __ ] but every once in a while he likes
to look back at uh secret origins [ __ ]
it mark's got the news give it up for
mark with the news news
uh
so
okay
uh i think we all have certain feelings
about the way game of thrones ended
some of us have great feelings about it
right yeah anyone loved it i mean look
yeah
it's a lot of yeah so much of it was
[ __ ] amazing
that the landing was bumpy like it
doesn't make me go like [ __ ] that show i
still think of like the red wedding
[ __ ] episode
still think of like [ __ ] you know
her being like this isn't a negotiation
[ __ ] the dragon shows up she fires up
all the ships and there's so many like
magical moments in that show that even
like the last episode being what it was
or the last season being what it was
didn't pooch the whole thing for me no
no um and we have more game of thrones
coming there's a [ __ ] ton of game of
thrones coming on the pike we get house
of the dragon in august there's two or
three live-action shows already in
development
and one of them seems to be a jon snow
sequel show
is all right that's right kit harrington
is attached to reprise the role should a
series move forward um he was twice
nominated for an emmy um
in the eighth and final season jon snow
discovered that he was actually aegon
targaryen
you're going to want some blue shoot
you're going to have to
um
and yes since apparently
not continuing in any more eternal
movies kit harrington was like yo give
me another franchise and so he is coming
back and george r martin is apparently
on board with whatever they're going to
be doing which nobody really knows he
just left to go be king up in the north
beyond the wall
and so now we're going to discover what
that is or you
is anybody
interested
okay
i already got hbo so i'll [ __ ] watch
it would you have rathered a jon snow
show or a pirate aria show
i would have watched that that would
have been more amazing absolutely
um well you're not getting we have both
i don't know
i mean
maybe there's a version in which she
appears in the show maybe we're just
going to continue this sort of stark
children as they go forward it's unclear
so much of this is still wet clay
but
it seems to be a thing that's that's on
the [ __ ] drawing boards
um
george rr martin is like money is coming
money is gone
has he ever finished writing
i i fear that he still hasn't finished
even though they finished
a while ago and he got to see their
finish and see what they didn't be like
i just have to do the opposite of that
he's still not done man [ __ ] that
i'll never feel bad about missing a
deadline in my life
yeah so hey man like hbo is and maybe
this is part of the new directive from
the new boss
um now the discovery and it's always
weird to say this the discovery bought
warner brothers
but they did and the new boss is like
franchises give me [ __ ] that makes money
give me [ __ ] that brings eyeballs to hbo
you know what i'll do it [ __ ] jon
snow
i guess that makes sense yeah so we're
getting it he's like you know what ain't
gonna do it the [ __ ] 200 million
dollar jj abrams show
yeah or the wonder twins movie yeah
nobody wants that what uh did jj find a
home for that show yet um not that it
has been announced is that right yeah i
thought that'd be snapped up quick
somebody else be like yeah we'll [ __ ]
do it i mean it might be we just have an
announcement yeah good point
um meanwhile kevin feige has now teased
the enemy
you all right [ __ ]
that name gives me such pleasure
it's just the [ __ ] only kevin in this
world that matters really
kevin [ __ ] foggy man he's he's doing
the lord's work man i i did not expect
to enjoy movies this
deeply into my
adulthood like you know middle age
[ __ ] i'm an old man 51. i expected
like oh i'd grow old my taste would grow
old and [ __ ] that dude still has a
[ __ ] magic recipe
to make me feel the way i felt when i
would sit in a movie theater in the 80s
and he hasn't dropped the ball yet so
god bless him man he's my favorite
[ __ ] storyteller right now for me i'm
not saying he's the world's best i'm
saying for what i'm looking for what
makes me [ __ ] happy he does it on a
consistent [ __ ] bases and i don't say
this going i want a job i never want to
work there unless you want me to cameo
in something i would do that in a
heartbeat kevin feige but like [ __ ] i
angling for a job to like make a thing
that [ __ ] seems too hard i just love
what they do over there man and i love
that he's
he seems to know what he's doing every
once in a while i read a thing on the
internet where like he has no plan i was
like well if that's the [ __ ] case
then let him [ __ ] continue to wing it
because i've loved everything they've
done so far
uh speaking of him and not having the
eternals [ __ ] that was long
god damn it
not bad but just [ __ ] long and [ __ ]
but well made
kevin feige is as as we're coming up on
thor loving thunder's release
that looks [ __ ] amazing brett deacon
invited us to go see it in 4dx oh man my
loins you're not ready for that you can
you imagine tiger ytd movie and [ __ ]
40x and [ __ ] you'll be coming the whole
time man that chair won't stop moving oh
that movie's gonna be [ __ ] amazing
[Music]
as we're nearing the end of phase four
says kevin feige i think people will
start to see where this next saga is
going where do you think it's going um
secret wars secret war seems like a
pretty logical guess
um he says uh in an interview with total
film i think there have been many clues
already
that are at least apparent to me of
where this whole sock is going but we'll
be a little more direct about what that
is
in the coming months to set a plan so
audiences who want to see the bigger
picture can get a tiny tiny bit more of
the road map
and the coming months are going to bring
us a thor loving thunder
um and they're also gonna bring d23
oh that's their disney's
comic-con yeah d23 expo 2022 which is in
september
and uh and they'll also be at san diego
comic-con but they'll probably save
their big guns for d23
and you know so who the [ __ ] knows what
they're going to announce
but secret wars is not a bad guess
what else could there be
like what are the other big storylines
they could take a swing at i never would
have imagined if somebody said where do
you think they're gonna take the marvel
universe like i wouldn't have said oh
they should go
infinity [ __ ] gauntlet that wouldn't
have been my first [ __ ] thing
yeah i mean i i it seemed like the
multiverse
was going to maybe be a bigger deal than
it seemed to have been
um
but maybe when we get ant-man and
quantum mania we'll see exactly what
kang is up to we'll see exactly what all
of that [ __ ] means how the tva plays
into that but that was like a big thread
that seemed like he was going to be
the domineering element of this and it
seems to kind of faded
um
what about galactus do you think that
could be it
well the fantastic four at some point
are coming they're coming so glad to
bring the table but yeah so like he
could be you want to talk about somebody
to replace thanos
holy [ __ ] like this fucker's coming to
eat the goddamn planet like that he's a
he's as big bad as you get man that's
that's pretty dope
um
but is there a dr doom story line that
would bring everybody
secret wars but he's just he's not
responsible for secret wars he's just
part of it
like how thanos was responsible for
everything that happened in the infinity
saga
well i mean there's the secret wars that
we grew up with with the beyonder and
then there's the circuit wars that
jonathan hickman sort of refashioned
much later on which has lots to do with
incursions and
planets on top of it they've brought
incursions into the marvel universe
right which i don't fully understand
because i that that was
a little bit advanced comics even for me
because hickman's brain is frighteningly
big and
the internet is happy to tell me mine is
not
so yeah so i never dug into that stuff
but i mean i'm here if we get super wars
in any fashion [ __ ] bring it
um they got to bring an x-men would you
bring x-men into the secret wars yes
you know i thought that multiverse of
madness was going to be the key that
unlocked all of that [ __ ] but it seems
like maybe secret wars is going to be
the key that gets to unlock x-men
fantastic four and deadpool and all of
that stuff like into the mcu prime
mm-hmm so super mcu prime
um so yeah whatever the [ __ ] it is i'm
happy for it um there was also talk once
upon a time that the russo boys
were interested in making a secret wars
movie yeah they said they'd come back
for that they said they'd come back for
that
um
and i would happily welcome them back
into the mcu yeah
um you mentioned a wonderman show
i did i got a prematurely wonder manned
all over our episode here tonight
um i i couldn't remember if that was
something i dream or something that i
passed by on the internet
um it's i haven't spent a lot of time my
[ __ ] you know they give you those
notices on your phone we're like your
screen time was up my screen time was
down 12 hours this week and that's
because i've been with my [ __ ] mom so
i wasn't sure if that news was real it
is real
[Music]
tell me about it shang chi and legend of
the ten rings filmmaker destin daniel
[ __ ]
has teamed up with andrew guest who was
a writer producer on brooklyn nine-nine
and community to tackle a live-action
series featuring the long-time marvel
character
i know very little about wonder man
what the [ __ ] the deal he's a west
coast avenger
he's a actor was a simon west
um
and that's all i know
who i remember that nathan fillion had a
cameo yeah like there's a poster in one
of the guardians i think guard guards
too
um well according to this year news post
wonder man is one of marvel's oldest
characters uh first introduced in 1964
on the pages of avengers number nine he
was initially a villain and only
appeared sporadically in the early
marvel age was reconceived as a hero and
an avengers in the late 1970s in the 80s
he came into his own simon williams was
a founding member of the los angeles
based west coast avengers
and he also developed strong ties to
classic and now blah blah
vision and scarlet witch um and at one
point there was um
romantic
feelings between
simon williams and wanda maximoff is
that right that is right
[ __ ] man um all right so he's getting a
show he's getting a show
um
the question that we started to pose
last week that we've been posing for the
last uh
eight weeks in our ongoing series that
we like to call ezra miller is
apparently an [ __ ] oh my god
[ __ ] could you imagine if you're warner
brothers i mean number one could you
imagine if you were
every person who's had to deal with
ezra miller like [ __ ] it never seems
to end [ __ ] well
but could you imagine if you're like
every day you open up the paper and
you're like please god no and you're
like oh my god again
it just doesn't [ __ ] stop at what
point they've already issued some sort
or i don't know if they've issued but
word is they're like we're never working
with this kid again
yeah i don't know if that's gonna be
enough though to save their picture i
mean vanity fair did a pretty good
summation roundup of where everything
stands
and ultimately it's
yes warner brothers have said that this
is going to be the one and only flash
movie starring
ezra miller that doesn't solve the
problem of they currently have a flash
movie starring ezra miller yeah um the
movie's coming out next summer and can
they count on him to lie low enough
that maybe people can forget that
they're restraining orders against him
based on recent history no
like because there's a seems to be a
story every other week or something and
you're saying this movie don't come out
for a year yeah june 2023
i don't know man that's a tough call i
don't run a studio and [ __ ] but like
if it were me
i might just be like where's christopher
plummer
sadly yeah dead i'm like all right
where's grant gustin you know yeah
and that's no disrespect to ezra miller
but like
ezra miller doesn't seem to respect
anybody else so i don't know that you
want that person
uh who's like out there slapping people
and and with the things that been
alleged that they have done
representing a [ __ ] superhero like
you know i know these movies mostly for
adults but kids do go to them and [ __ ]
and it's like
and this is supposed to be the linchpin
of their ongoing attempt to sort of
right the ship and set a new course
going forward for the justice league
and this had michael keaton back it had
ben affleck back both playing some
version of batman it had a bunch of
other [ __ ] surprises that we don't
know and can't possibly know until next
summer
but you know they spent 200 million
dollars on this movie so far
which is a lot of money
but
i'm pretty sure if i remember correctly
they gave zack snyder about 75 million
dollars
to continue his director's cut for
justice league yeah
if you threw another 75 million dollars
at this movie
you can erase ezra miller probably you
know like i mean you know what we don't
know but let's say
minimum 75 million probably 100 because
he's your main character
he's in every shot maybe you don't get
rid of
some of the running shots because those
are you know [ __ ] uh cg characters
anyway avatars so maybe you get to
reshape those in the computer i mean
it's it is a lot of work and
a lot of money but at this point it
seems like a lot of headaches like to
try to figure out like or to be like man
i hope things stay quiet for a year it's
like things haven't stayed quiet for
like a month so and if they say quiet
you got to put that dude out on a press
campaign you've got to march him in
front of journalists and reporters and
television cameras and expect and pray
that that guy's on his best behavior for
months
i mean this is it's apples and oranges
so it's an unfair comparison but like
look at what tom cruise just did on top
gun you could not [ __ ] avoid tc tc
was [ __ ] everywhere and the movie you
know had a lot of expectations going in
with people like oh i remember that
flick
he's done incredible [ __ ] business
but like he's your star movie's called
top gun maverick so he's out there doing
every bit of [ __ ] press this movie's
called the flash ezra miller plays the
flash so
you know you can't be like
let's have michael keaton do all the
press you know it's like it's gonna fall
on on the lead shoulders and they can't
you know do what they did with uh it
seemed like they did i don't know if
this was intentional but when westside
story came out there certainly wasn't a
lot of ansel elgort
whatever his name is right press it was
everybody else um they don't have that
luxury here this is the flash
what do you do yeah i say
yeah it's like you just
bite the bullet and spend the money yeah
like because this could be the beginning
of a [ __ ] franchise
and you know what happens if the movie
makes a billion dollars you think a
really gonna turn around be like we're
well we said we're gonna we're gonna
work with them and we're still not no
they'll be like you know what like
ezra's changed
yes he's on his best behavior now
um and again i'm not campaigning against
the kid but
i mean
who's been grooming 12 years old i think
that's allegedly allegedly yes if that's
the case
replace him with don cheadle i mean
did just have him be like look i'm here
get over it let's move on yeah it's like
i know i'm 60 years old and my knees
start really working let me tell you
something don cheadle's such an amazing
actor he could [ __ ] pull it off
um uh yeah boy it's gonna be interesting
to watch man like
this isn't a case of uh
when
they re-shot solo
i don't know what they'd spend up until
that point but that was a case of nobody
had you know [ __ ] seen the movie
nobody in the cast was in trouble or
anything like that somebody just made it
it was a taste maker choice i guess
kathy kennedy was like i don't like this
version let's make a whole ass other
version and [ __ ]
this is not that situation this is a
situation where it's like it don't that
you've got there's a problem
right at the center of your move right
in the lead of your movie and when you
go to sell this
is the problem going to be ameliorated
or is the problem going to be even worse
than it is now yeah i mean the narrative
for warner brothers should be
we realized that we made a movie with a
very talented actor who had lots of of
issues
we replaced that actor at great expense
and we realized that we could not go
forward in good faith and good
conscience and presenting this character
to families
given the baggage that this person
brings to it so we did what we feel is a
responsible thing
for both our filmmakers and our bottom
line if you got to say that corporately
politically socially environmentally
we we just it was a hard decision to
make but we made it and then that's the
story
the studio stared at the face of what
seemed to be an unsolvable problem and
they solved it oh they said warner
brothers should give you a couple bucks
it's a great idea you just gave it away
for free like that [ __ ] cinderella
idea
which i don't even remember i know but
it was good
um there's a fix right there yeah it'll
cost you money it's always going to cost
you money whatever version you do is
going to cost you some money yeah
uh what else we got um you know how
disney uh continues to make live-action
movies if they're animated
um yeah they won't stop man they keep
making money everybody's just like oh my
god i want to see what it looks like
live action oh it sucked
[Music]
oh they're doing another one i can't
wait to see what it looks like oh it
sucks so you know there's it's it's
somebody's buying these tickets so
they're gonna keep doing it yeah they're
doing another one which one hercules
really yeah
i mean all right
like i ain't against it but like what a
weird pull really
they're gonna do it as the musical
version um that seems to be their their
their they could literally hold any
devito play the same part
i mean i'm sure he's warming up yeah you
could still do it um who's directing guy
richie
wow
i
i did not expect that response from a
crowd well it's because when you say guy
ritchie people like [ __ ] snatch
not like hercules except he also
directed the live action aladdin which
made a billion dollars right so he's
that guy now he apparently is this guy
god bless him man i'm sure he's just
like [ __ ] you silent bill you know how
much money i make like hell yeah i'm
making [ __ ] hercules and [ __ ] and
then make me maybe i'll make another
snatch just to shut you the [ __ ] up
god bless him man yeah i it feels
i get it like there might be some kind
of like oh let's see if we can
pull it off or whatever i get it there's
a huge check attached so why wouldn't
you do it yeah it is it is a money grab
hercules is a weird choice to me though
with the entire disney catalog
like what have they done so far they did
the lion king
jungle book aladdin jungle book beauty
and the beast beauty and the beast which
was very successful they're doing the
mulan
they're just doing love
little mermaid little mermaid is still
in the hop and the [ __ ] is like a
disney plus movie what
they did [ __ ] dumbo
all right so what's left that they
haven't done you could still do snow
white in the seven dwarfs but that'd be
weird
are they doing it
yeah that's right they announced that
so what do they have are they like what
a [ __ ] maybe they're like look all we
got left is [ __ ] hercules well they
got pocahontas
they got a it's like an atlantis they
got lilo and stitch
oh i would [ __ ] if guy richie's like
i'm making a live action lilo and stitch
you got every [ __ ] penny i got man
what are the legacy titles i guess
they've done them all
no peter pan bambi bambi
[ __ ] dark
yeah bambi if they one thing they should
learn from that lion king movie though
if they make bambi's they gotta give
them cartoon eyes don't make them look
like real deers real deers are just
[ __ ] they just look at you like and
yeah
they got one [ __ ] expression they're
never like oh mom they're just like
and they're asking so you caught them
jerking off just this all the time are
they [ __ ] you don't like deer i
think deers are [ __ ] why
i
they're so sweet are they sweet though
yeah they're [ __ ] are you sure i
think they're gentle because i think
they're [ __ ]
i think most animals are [ __ ] we
just impart some level of
anthropomorphism like oh he's so cute
like no dolphins are dicks apparently
dolphins are the worst i think there are
bad apples everywhere but i think
generally
i think generally dolphins are you know
they help us against sharks i've read in
in books
storybooks
and free willy i saw that dolphins might
not be so bad yeah they [ __ ] talk in
high pitches they're cute man
all right we'll be [ __ ] on dolphins
man nobody wants that nobody came here
for dolphin no way what was the first
time i'm laying in like oh dear dear
dear i think you're [ __ ] too deer
are so pretty and [ __ ] but i do feel
like the new jersey state flag should
have a dead deer on it
because my god when i was just back in
jersey [ __ ] there are dead deer
everywhere it's like somebody picked
this up it's depressing could you
imagine if you're a deer and you're
looking out and you see a bunch of dead
deer on the road you must be like
the [ __ ] man no deers land pick that
[ __ ] up no deers land indeed i'm always
told by people though their brains are
small they don't think about that [ __ ]
[ __ ] man i guarantee you if a deer a
live deer sees a dead deer on the side
of the road it's not just like
it's like holy [ __ ] oh the humanity or
the dear manatee or whatever the [ __ ]
like i life is precious and short i
we've got to live every day to the
fullest
phil is that you
bam
you you know what animals do when they
see a dead
like comrade
go crazy are crows
so we have we live in like the
mount like in the foothills of the
mountains right and there are
tens of thousands of crows in the
neighborhood
and uh a murder of crows if you will yes
a murderer of growth we never get to use
that experience parliament of rooks
perhaps i know and uh
they're everywhere and they like eat our
citrus they're menaces and uh
we went to the shop and they were like
if you get a stuffed crow and you put it
in your backyard on its side
the crows will go absolutely bonkers and
then leave for like two weeks until they
get comfortable enough to come back so
we bought it we took it home
and it yeah i mean it was like alfred
hitchcock's the birds it was so [ __ ]
loud and crazy
hundreds of crows screaming and then
they all flew away
they [ __ ] off yeah they were all
insulted though like you think this is
what a [ __ ] crow looks like piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] let's get out of here
there's citrus elsewhere
um really man
i wouldn't chase them away i'd be buying
crow food what are they what do they eat
what do they like
uh garbage oh [ __ ] then i got lots of
crow food man
let's open up the cans and [ __ ] that's
right man flesh oh [ __ ] well i would
still take my chances they're a pretty
badass looking bird man that's a wise
bunch of birds um the the birds outside
of my house i got a lot of
[ __ ] turtle doves like in the song
that's like two but we got [ __ ] 100.
and i get them seed and [ __ ] i feed the
birds all the time i started feeding the
squirrels but then the birds just
started coming along and i was like [ __ ]
off this is for the squirrels and i
realized you can't do that and [ __ ]
then i started getting enjoyment out of
the birds more so than the squirrels and
i was like [ __ ] off to the squirrels
because the birds were like communal
squirrels come at it
like you put out a gazillion peanuts man
one squirrel's there another squirrel
shows up he just leaves it all to fight
that [ __ ] squirrel
and it's like look at all these [ __ ]
nuts what are you crazy what are you
nuts but the birds you got multiple
piles they all come it's like family and
all hanging out and they're chirping at
each other eating together they don't
chase each other it's [ __ ] it's nice
this is what i this is kev's nature show
this episode of mutual of omaha is
brought to you by blue chew it's yes uh
well this is an excellent segue into our
next news item good which is about who
exactly is craven the hunter in the new
craven the hunter movie oh
i heard this man let me tell you who i
believe craving the hunter to be yeah
craving the hunter in the comics was a
hunter yeah so much so that he wanted to
hunt the greatest game there is uh the
[ __ ] the most dangerous game
man not just man spider-man indeed so he
killed animals craven wears a
shirt or whatever the [ __ ] outfit
that's a lion's mane a face of a lion
split down his [ __ ] bare [ __ ]
chest with his eight pack and [ __ ]
gutters and [ __ ] like that so
he is it's right in the name mark i
don't even know why you're asking craven
comma
the hunter and
we've always assumed rightly because
every comic book story has been about
this that he hunts animals yes that's
his whole jam there it is he's the
second best wearer of a
lion's head on their on their outfit
first best
king joffrey james yes
but in an interview with variety aaron
taylor johnson who's playing craven the
hunter uh describes the villain as one
of marvel's most iconic notorious
anti-heroes
never been true never been an anti-hero
always been a villain yes spider-man's
number one anti-hero he means villain
he's absolutely right yes
uh spider-man's number one rival and
noted how he wait wait wait
yeah he the boy said what
spider-man's number one rival all right
kid back the [ __ ] up like
come on there's a reason craven been in
the has not been in the movies you know
you know ever
um and green goblin's been in like
almost every one of them green goblin is
spider-man's joker everybody knows that
fair enough everybody my mother [ __ ]
knows that for this kid to be throwing
around craving as spider-man's number
one villain
[ __ ] insults me mark
then just you wait oh [ __ ] there's more
he said that the character is not an
alien or a wizard he's just a hunter a
human with conviction
however a human with conviction yeah
he's like i love to kill animals right
johnson then confirmed how craven is an
animal lover what
and a protector of the natural world
what
what is a swamp thing
oh no is this the direction they're
taking the character yes of course it is
because how do you build a franchise on
a piece of [ __ ] who wants to shoot
elephants it's like building a [ __ ]
movie franchise on donald trump jr so
the notion of [ __ ] like that's not
political that's just me going i don't
like people who kill animals he has done
so we've seen the pictures we've seen
the pictures online so you know clearly
an unpopular [ __ ] choice to be like
hey you know the guy that hates animals
he's our leading man and [ __ ]
um that puts you into like flash
problematic problematic country in terms
of marketing so i guess what they're
doing is turning them into
an anti-hero like venom or something
like that and so maybe craving the
hunter
if he's a friend to all animals like
brainy smurf as they're [ __ ] saying
right now
maybe their version of craven the hunter
is a hunter who hunts the hunters
he's a poacher poacher he's a guy who
kills the poachers and [ __ ] which
wonderful but not craven the hunter no
also at all the complete literally the
opposite of craving the hunter the only
thing it shares in common is a name that
could work both ways
um well kelly it will be uh it will be
it'll be morbid time with craven on uh
january 13th 2023
so we can see how they once again take a
bad guy and make him a good guy because
they ran out of spider-man [ __ ] to make
a movie of
um well i hope they don't morbid
but it sounds like that's a kooky
decision right there i mean i get it
it's a smart business decision but then
don't do craven
right do anyone else if you have to do
craven sure nobody's saying you have to
do great yeah craven should be a bad guy
at least start him as a [ __ ] bad guy
i mean and but to fundamentally change
everything about him so why is he wear
that lion thing he doesn't every picture
just has him with a nice linen white
shirt
but that's not from the movie yeah
seriously that's him i mean i don't know
if he's wearing it in every scene big
jaffee
there's a butt screen
where is my son you're right he wore it
so much but who wore it better he
totally did killed it
um all right well look you know when it
comes on tv i'll [ __ ] see it
hbo max i'm sure it'll be something like
that if it's like i that that's just to
me is like why would you do that i get
why you do it but then
there must be a marvel character
that [ __ ] likes
animals and [ __ ] like that yeah look at
it calling you
hello what's next
uh the next story is our last story and
it is a somewhat sad story oh [ __ ] which
we end up doing with frightening
regularity these days um but the great
dc and marvel comics art artist tim sale
passed away
what the [ __ ] are you serious
yeah did you not know this i did not tim
sales like in my mind tim cell is really
young he was 66 years old
tim sale was 66 years old [ __ ] he looked
young man
i did not know this are you kidding me i
am not kidding you i have so much tim
cell art i am a massive [ __ ] tim
suffer look at him look how young he
looks i mean that might be an old
picture but look how young he looks
[ __ ] i didn't know this at all oh my god
god i loved him and i loved the way
that he drew batman [ __ ] i was gonna
reach out to him to do a cover for
[ __ ] secret stash press
i mean i'm you know i'm that's not the
reason i'm sad he's gone i'm sad that
such a major talent is gone but
i if i'd reached out sooner i might have
hit him before [ __ ] he left [ __ ]
yeah uh the the cause of death is yet to
be revealed
but he did check into the hospital you
know i want to say it was last monday
and he did not last very long
um
66 66
and if he's in shape with tim sales work
tim sale is one of the great batman
artists if you're not familiar with tim
sales work chances are you are familiar
with tim sales work you just didn't know
his [ __ ] name but
you're absolutely right one of the
premier batman artists of all time he
worked very closely with jeff loeb on a
series of [ __ ] books that have been
insanely influential right up until the
most recent the batman movie as well the
long halloween dark victory they did a
catman book called when in rome they
they're halloween special halloween
special they started their partnership
on challenges of the unknown oh
oh my god you just took me back one of
my favorite comic book series absolutely
of all time a series that i went into
going like i'm just buying issue number
one because it's a number one i don't
give a [ __ ] about this book and the
storytelling and the art was so [ __ ]
magnetic that i stayed in and it became
one of my absolute [ __ ] favorites so
much so that i'm like whatever these
cats do i'm following and they did go on
to not only the batman stuff but of
course they did a whole run of marvel
stuff as well didn't they do
hulk they did captain america white they
did uh spiderman blue hulk gray yes
daredevil yellow yes um and they also
did the amazing superman for all seasons
yes oh my god where i sort of
dove into tim sale for the first time oh
i'm gonna cry [ __ ] he was so talented
and such a nice man
he's a big part of my childhood in the
entertainment business because i
gravitated toward people whose work i
[ __ ] loved and [ __ ] and so
at comic cons like these were the people
that i wanted to meet and he was such a
good [ __ ] guy god damn it he was so
[ __ ] talented too i love
all of his artwork
this is a huge [ __ ] loss
normally i go into these shows knowing
you know
like
not everything but
i didn't know this holy [ __ ]
anyway
what are your thoughts
uh
i'm sorry to have to be the person to
break that news yeah and again i don't
want it to seem like we were best
friends but i i
he was such a nice dude dude for
somebody with that much talent he didn't
have to be that nice really [ __ ]
talented geniuses
can get away with treating you like an
[ __ ] and you're really like oh my god
they're so talented and [ __ ] this guy
was such a nice guy and [ __ ] could he
draw i love the way he drew
yeah i mean it's it's i i never got to
meet him i i got to email with him a
couple of times back for a project that
never happened where we were hoping he
would do covers and he was so [ __ ]
sweet about it
um and just seemed to be the kind of
person who loved to draw yeah i was like
i'm doing this creator on book and we
just think you'd be great and it's like
yeah [ __ ] it if i'm free i'm happy to do
it and it just the book never happened
and he went off to be tim sale and doing
tim sales [ __ ] and you know never heard
from him again but just there was the
level of of grace and joy with which he
seemed to attack everything
that uh you know again we're we're
losing too many guys like this and we're
losing two and that one is like 66 man
like that's like a year younger than my
dad and i always thought my dad he died
67 i thought that was pretty [ __ ]
young 66 and he was in good shape my dad
was in terrible shape tim sale like
physically seemed fit to me from a
distance
um jesus
[ __ ]
that blows yeah we'll never see his like
again but you know what rather than
[ __ ]
curse the darkness let's light a candle
we are lucky
that we got the amount of work we got
out of him before he [ __ ] left man
raise it up for the great tim sale
oh
[ __ ]
that's the news my friend yeah
bummer sorry we should have led with
that
then we could have [ __ ] closed with
something else but we can close with
[ __ ] q a man that's true maybe q a
will lift our spirits and [ __ ] um all
right
we did the news man give it up for mark
you did the [ __ ] news everybody
the news was done
[Applause]
all right what do we got
uh jc banff man
all right
uh we've got some questions
uh the first is from hold on before we
do that
we got
um
how do we do that one
i don't know we have fourth question or
do we just do it as a special
maybe a fourth question i i do have four
questions oh i have a back up so we'll
save that for the end
yeah that's the last one
and then we'll say what it is at the end
okay somebody feels shitty exactly so
everyone's like i want that one and [ __ ]
um all right folks
those who ask a question
and if the question is good
uh and generally it always is they're
gonna walk away with this sweet ass
prize a copy of adora and the distance
written by an amazing [ __ ] writer
who's up for a [ __ ] award
an eisner in a couple weeks
[Applause]
mr mark bernard and say your artist's
name ariella kristen tina
that's how i would just find it slower
it is very fun to say um you're gonna
get a copy of that book signed by the
guy himself and you're also gonna get
two
screen x tickets to go see whatever you
want but guess what go see elvis it's
coming out and [ __ ] like that uh they
also they they just had their highest
grossing
uh picture ever on screen x and it was a
top gun they also did a 40x top gun but
the screen x top gun it does all three
sides so you feel like you're in the
cockpit uh screen x tickets are gonna be
yours if
your question is picked and
it's really good so
jc take over all right uh first question
yusef nash
yusef
come on up everyone give it up for
yousef you said
all right you said oh look at him
wearing a shirt
he's a very sartorially swift kind of
guy yeah
i forgot to dress up for this event you
know do you wore the right [ __ ] you
made the right choice my friend oh thank
you thank you um so
you know i grew up muslim you know my
family's from iraq and like
watching miss marvel and sing at her
house like it it really looked like the
house i grew up in you know this is a
very like very close like one guy
outside the culture i'm like is this
pandering or is this a perfect portrait
of the i tell you there's just like this
um
this this like diamond shaped
portrait with like chronic writing and
like i'm pretty sure my family has that
same exact one really yeah it looks
eerily the same and i just like started
tearing up because like i can't believe
something this big showing like islam
inside a positive way especially in this
country you know when like every guy
that kind of looked like me was just
wants to kill the company because like
which is weird because i was in the air
force it was like i don't i don't hate
the country like yeah i served
um that's beautiful i bet that's what
they were hoping for when they made the
[ __ ] show yeah like the idea that
somebody could see the show and be like
hey i'm up there man yeah it it really
i i had a hard time being objective
watching it because i'm just like god
everything i'm seeing just like i love
and so my question for you guys is like
for me seeing that was like i just
started crying because i saw this one
little thing in the background did you
guys ever had like a moment where you
were just like
oh man i saw something in the background
and i just like you just like tear it up
or you're just like holy [ __ ] like
everything about the movie no matter how
bad it was or how good it was doesn't
matter like because of this one thing or
this one thing in the background you saw
it just like made the whole thing for
you [ __ ] hey yeah because it
the best chances of
that happening are probably in a movie
or tv show because you have a chance to
feel seen right because you're deep in
the [ __ ] story you're in their story
and you've made this contract with the
storytellers where you're like i'm in
your world it's your world you're
telling the story
take me there
if they reach out to your world like
when i was a kid if they mentioned new
jersey still today as an adult if they
are you know watching ms marvel and [ __ ]
they're like jersey city i'm like they
know we exist
it was [ __ ] thrilling to be
acknowledged as a [ __ ] state never
mind like if they had ever been like and
this is the jersey shore which they did
in a movie called don't go into the
house it was a horror movie that was
shot in atlantic highlands new jersey
and shot outside of this this creepy old
house that still exists and shot outside
the atlantic highlands movie theater
where i went to the movies all the time
so anytime i watch that movie i'm like
holy [ __ ] they like i've been there i
know where that [ __ ] pay phone is
so there have definitely been moments
like that there have been movies that
have moments that made me feel seen um
it's i know it's like
dated and controversial for a lot of
folks but the bad news bears
is always a movie that will always make
me feel like oh [ __ ] they knew my
childhood it wasn't the random ass
general entertainment childhood of
[ __ ] you know most tv shows and
movies
[ __ ] up kids were my childhood and
seeing those fuck-up kids being bad at
little league that was my childhood so i
always felt seen when i [ __ ] watched
something like that i know that feeling
man um so it's a thrilling feeling do
you know um i have i have two examples i
have one that that that still thrills me
to this day and i have one that i always
feel
the more i engage with it the more i
feel like it's not living up to its
potential to do exactly what you're
talking about
um
in spider-man into the spider-verse
when biggie comes on like it's lily it's
just that [ __ ] song
it's just hypnotized and like
suddenly i'm that kid in that age
listening to that music for the first
time in new york and just thrilled to be
like
alive and [ __ ] like with my friends
and like doing like there's just this
spirit that comes out of that moment in
that movie
um where he just shouts brooklyn from
the [ __ ] rooftops because he's so
much in love with this particular moment
in time and there's a lot into the
spider-verse that that i mean i'm not
after latino but i'm half of that um but
i'm a new yorker and so there's there's
parts of that movie that absolutely do
speak to me about growing up in new york
the one that i keep hoping for more from
is is stranger things
because it takes place
in the 80s
i am i am the same age that those kids
would have been at that time is that
right in 1986 where you were you're born
71.
so i'd have been 15. i would have been
in my sophomore junior year of high
school
i was lucas on that show i was that
black kid i was the black kid who played
d dnd and who read comics who hung out
with a mostly white click of friends
because my black friends who i still
hung out with but they didn't swing with
that [ __ ] the way i did
but
the the access to both white spaces and
black spaces and the the way that you
have to find a way to exist in both
seems like a story they are primed to be
able to tell with that character i get
it that show's about 11 and it's about
will and it's about [ __ ] hopper and
getting him out of russia and all that
stuff i get what the show's about but
that character of lucas is who i was and
i don't see myself in him you know i
don't see
the the particular and you don't have to
make a show about it but there's ways to
make that guy just feel real that the
show doesn't quite go the length to do
and i'm not sure who's in the writers
room i'm not sure who is helping to tell
that story but
to see
to get that that like so close to it
like you have almost all the pieces
except it seems as if you're not that
interested in this guy
then that's a bit heartbreaking to me
and so
that's that's the one that i keep hoping
for more from and don't get and
spider-verse remains the gift that keeps
on giving um i have you ever seen a
movie called brigsby bear a lot of
people have not
um i that that was a surprise i got a
surprising
backdoor gift from that movie which
sounds exactly as sexy as i meant it um
because on the surface it's a movie
about like hey this kid was raised in a
[ __ ] under
a world where he thought everyone was
dead and now he's got to reintegrate
into society
that was the movie i was expecting
in that movie they
part of his uh part of the story is is
the parents who had kidnapped him as a
child and raised him made a program for
him called brigsby bear that was like
directed at him guy made like [ __ ]
hundreds of episodes of the show and
there's no end to the show so when this
kid got free or whatever the [ __ ] his
biggest concern was like where's the
latest brigsby bear because that's what
he did his whole [ __ ] life so
eventually he decides to make
the final episode of brigsby bear oh my
god i'm gonna cry talking about it
so
there's a moment of pure [ __ ]
creative exuberance which i was not
expecting an absolutely [ __ ] adore
when they're all out making the [ __ ]
movie as i'm watching the movie i didn't
like connect with it on that level of oh
[ __ ] they're doing what i do
i was kind of in their store i was in
their world
and then they did something that they
[ __ ] acknowledged me
and he's so
overjoyed um it's kyle mooney who's
amazing in the movie and should have
been nominated for awards
he's uh so overjoyed with like him and
his new friends making this thing that
he just starts talking
at the camera and he starts saying
exactly
what they're doing and i don't know the
words exactly but he's just like like
it's easy to make a make a tv show all
you have to do is get your friends and
you just come out you just have a good
time and it's so
simple and childlike like the character
but i i wept when it happened because i
was like yes [ __ ] like
that's exactly what it is that's how i
feel and then i started going like wait
am i an idiot like this guy in the movie
and [ __ ] but then i'm like yes because
i'm a happy idiot because i make my [ __ ]
i felt very seen by that [ __ ] moment
it will endear that movie to me for the
rest of my [ __ ] life
excellent question give it up for yousef
man thank you
i uh
i have two answers to that question
i have a good one and a bad one okay
the bad one was i think it was last year
two years ago i swatched eight-bit
christmas with doogie hauser
and i just like
i was like oh this is
him as a little kid is me he's like
too poor and can't afford a nintendo and
all he wants is a nintendo and his
parents figure out how to get him a
nintendo and it's all looks like my
neighborhood and i watched a whole movie
waiting to be like wowed and i was like
i kind of hate that movie
you like it i didn't like it at all so
it got me but it didn't get me kind of
like it was like march
and then the other one was
in 1999 i went to film school i
was my freshman year of college my first
semester and i went to the movie theater
and i saw a movie called dogma where
they were jay and silent bob were
talking about going to shermer illinois
and i just
moved my hometown in shermer illinois so
i just moved from shermer illinois to go
to film school and somebody's making a
movie about
their their heroes are trying to get to
shermer illinois and i was like oh
look at that that's pretty cool
yeah that guy's a genius i hope to work
with him one day
it's a long con
[ __ ] works out that's amazing i'm happy
to be part of your [ __ ] memory um all
right what's the next
uh frankie frank and julia
[Music]
frank and julie get up are you those
coming up together as a team are those
two people or is it like frank and
furter
here they come give it up for frank and
julia
i suppose it could have been frank t
julia but there we go
qui-gon slipping by with some drinks
what's up kids i wasn't expecting this
uh but
nobody expects the spanish inquisition
yeah um
before i start i just want to say i
wasn't a big comic book fan until i
started watching you guys and seeing
some of the passion obviously the movie
there we go gotcha
i appreciate it so thanks for getting me
in on that for those if you missed it he
was saying that he wasn't a big comic
book person until he started watching
this [ __ ] show yeah yeah we've done
our jobs now we can retire indeed we all
we said when we started this we just
need to convert one person frank and or
julie [ __ ] it we did it
now we can we can walk off into the corn
fields
okay so um my husband was telling me he
he listens to you guys all the time and
so
i i was he was telling me about the
question and answered he's like people
ask questions like this and i was
cracking up i was like do they really
ask that question he's like no i'm like
okay then that's what we're gonna do
okay right on
if you had to remake and recast three
men and a baby which avengers would you
put
and why
excellent [ __ ] question wow
excellent question he's absolutely right
that is the kind of question we answer
it's the specificity of it that i
appreciate all right let's walk it
through again because some of us are
stoned if we're
remaking three men and a baby and for
the record no need to remake it leonard
nimoy did an amazing job give it up for
spock everybody spock the director
but
if we're remaking it
and we have to do it with avengers only
do you do we have supporting characters
within the avengers or just avengers
anyway we want anybody that's been in an
adventure
yeah absolutely okay
um tom selleck is a mustache actor
we need stan lee in that role oh stanley
he's in an avengers movie he counts he
does yes um if we can't get him let's
think of another guy okay do you want to
do your three in a row do you want me to
go now you go ahead
uh i want i want michael pena
for man
excellent pull that he needs to be the
he's one of the dads one of the dads the
bedtime storyteller
now my turn now it's your turn um
um
let's see oh you know i know a lot of
people [ __ ] on them but like [ __ ] uh
hawkeye with that recent miniseries
uh proved to be very fatherly so yeah
let's let's let's let renner go in there
okay app or no app i'm taking jeremy
renner
uh i'm i'm going to go with baku hawkeye
meaning hawkeye oh yeah excellent like
winston's win
yes because he seems to be like he's a
dude who likes to have people sit on his
giant massive thighs and and bounce them
uh he's wait we're still talking about
being a dad right yeah yeah no but
you're you're bouncing a top like that's
what you're doing uh he's a vegetarian
so the kid will grow up healthy true
uh and he doesn't take any mess from
anyone that's true
um i go tony stark he seemed like a
pretty amazing dad his kid loved him
[ __ ] 3 000.
so
he told him to love him you told her 11
3 000.
did he he was like how much do you love
me well yeah he he
came up with it yeah but he exhorts the
love out of his kid well he's like i
love you he should i love you
i love you more yeah i love you three
thousand she upped his game she did he
didn't want that though he seemed
surprised by it yeah too much didn't
walk out of the scene going like that's
what i [ __ ] thought
he was so touched by it that's why you
know what [ __ ] put robert downey jr
in every movie so [ __ ] charming and
wonderful but particularly i thought he
was a wonderful and charming dad in uh
in end game so yeah there's my guy
is that your third one
yeah i don't know if stan counts though
i mean look stan counts let's be honest
but i don't know if we can make a
current movie
without a lot of cgi be an expensive
movie so i've got someone a mulligan on
stan yeah
do you have one more to go i got one
more to go go
groot
that's a [ __ ] great call man cause
nobody will care for that kid the way
groot cares for that kid that's true
excellent [ __ ] call
um
all right let me oh [ __ ] what are we
kidding
america's dad america's ass but
america's dad captain america
[ __ ] who'll be more wholesome to
raise a kid and [ __ ] he could teach him
to box something my father never did for
me
still think about that
if you were a boxer and he never told me
to [ __ ] box he was like you're too
soft to box
and he was right
uh all right well i think we did it i
think we did it oh my god great
questions you guys win the [ __ ] books
tickets in a book
well done kids well um
yeah totally
i think uh i think it's a crime that
scott lang isn't on there after getting
that hideous bunny as a birthday present
for his daughter and the only thing he
cares about when he gets through
the
you know shrinking down is getting back
to his daughter and he learned close-up
magic for his daughter you're absolutely
[ __ ] right and i don't know what it
says about me or
the movie that like that's not the first
thing that popped in my head like if you
said ant-man to me i'd be like oh it's
about him being a dad but you're right
it's all about him being a dad but for
some reason that movie to me is about
him shrinking i actually
the the thing that got me is i was like
paul rudd reminds me of a much better
steve guttenberg
and he's a good dad that's some shade
thrown into it man
you know how many police academies i did
that's not easy
and short circuit excellent point 25 is
a lot yeah uh all right uh next question
bobby
rodulla rodila
bobby give it up
[Applause]
we saw you on the way to the bathroom
which sounds real [ __ ] sus but like
that's where we hang out right before
the show begins we like to see who's
[ __ ] no we just that's where the
hallway is inside the over under that's
right how are you bob i'm good i'm good
i'm uh i'm here with my dad rick holy
hey hey we saw him doing the hallway i i
remember that was yesterday wasn't it
how old are you
[ __ ] turn 54 years young give it up
for a wreck man i i think we we might
have to sing
we can sing you want us to sing you want
a song
[ __ ] yeah the song's free everybody kick
it in one two three happy birthday to
you
rick happy
happy
birthday to
yeah
54. well done
put them on the glass back to you
well done holy [ __ ] what a great thing
to do for your day like i was telling
you when we met earlier
parents met in a movie theater they were
around your age when clerks came out
yeah when they were still working in a
movie theater and that's when i was born
so growing up in the household i had all
your films in the house starting from
clerks all the way to chasing amy all
rats dog by all of it my god you were
raised a generation of kevin smith i was
and you know it's due to having such
young parents who worked in defense
parents with such great taste exactly
right so it's crazy so i or his birthday
father's day and everything what better
way to come down all the way from san
francisco then to see youtube they came
in from san francisco for the show what
a great gift well done he's had he's had
a good week you know father's day we had
the day off yesterday and everything so
i took him to the baseball game took him
a lunch and now we're here
excellent um so my question at all bring
the mic up right in your mouth um my
question at the end of all of it is
if you both were to take your dad on a
birthday trip what would you do
wow
wow
take dad on a birthday trip how's your
relationship with your dad
you know
we're both men so fraught
um
i think i think every every man will
tell you that they have some unresolved
issue with their father um trust me
trust me i know yeah yeah and i i i'm no
different
um
i don't know it's funny like i my dad is
from haiti
and hasn't been back in what's gotta be
at this point now like 30 years
um
not because he doesn't want to go but
because it's actually unsafe for him to
be there it's it's a it's a pretty
dangerous place down there
so if in particular just in general in
general for like expats to return i was
like what kind of [ __ ] story is that
you're like my dad fled he can't [ __ ]
go back i'm like that's [ __ ] tell that
story yeah um
so like it would be nice to be able to
take him back um
and to be in the position to be able to
make that happen would be lovely um
it doesn't seem like the wisest choice
um for
our safety
but i think
he told me this story when he was out
here most recently from my son's
graduation that when he left haiti he
went to london to learn how to speak
english
and was like washing dishes and [ __ ]
like that and just whatever it took to
to make ends meet so then he could leave
london and come to the united states and
for whatever reason london was cheaper
than new york
so i don't know why the [ __ ] that was
stop number one but i feel like
returning back to london with him
and getting those first memories
of what it was like to be young and
leaving with ambition and
and that the feeling of promise you know
that you have when you're 19 20 years
old and you think the world can be yours
and you can bend it to your will if you
can just be good enough it's smart
enough and speak right and all that
stuff and so to be able to go back and
walk those same streets with him and see
where he first cut his teeth um as a man
in the world um would i think be kind of
special at least for me i don't know if
he wants to go but i'd [ __ ] go
um
my dad uh passed away some time ago um
uh 19 years ago
at the beginning of this month next year
will be 20 years that he's gone
so
spending any time of course would uh
would be amazing um how long do i have a
week
sure yeah go ahead say it more than one
day i'm getting greedy well he's had a
three-day birthday extravaganza i'll
take three days
um number one we're gonna podcast
uh something i never did while he was
alive that came after he was gone
and it would have been amazing
to dive deep you want to talk about
darth vader looking out the window and
you're like what's that [ __ ] thinking
that was my father except he didn't kill
a bunch of kids and [ __ ] like that he
was you never knew what he was thinking
he was inscrutable and when he asked him
he got defensive like why why do you
want to know and stuff he just didn't
come from a very open generation
so i would sit him down and be like bro
you're talking and i'd make mom be with
him so she'd [ __ ] do half the talking
as she did mostly in his life as well so
it would be
like old home week so definitely i'm
recording podcasts with him at my house
um i'm going to the movies with him
oddly enough you'd imagine like you get
him back all you want to do is talk to
him we talked to each other with movies
he took me to the movies and he
communicated with them and that's how i
learned
about life in general not just like
movies and themselves and stuff and he
wasn't trying to
film school educate me just like look
the fat one likes movies we'll go see
movies and [ __ ] but sitting next to your
father i've said this many times sitting
next to your father in the dark watching
movies you will learn a lot about who
your father absolutely is yes it's
you know you see what makes him laugh
you see what makes him think you see
what makes him [ __ ] feel what makes
him cry i'll never forget watching my
father cry
in the world according to garp and being
like
you're allowed to do that like [ __ ]
it's okay to because i feel emotional i
don't know what it is but like i guess
i'm feeling something too but i didn't
know you really
permission was granted to just you know
[ __ ] enjoy what was happening
as emotionally as one could like just
imbibe just buy into the whole [ __ ]
thing and if it makes you laugh of
course but if it makes you feel it makes
you cry [ __ ] go for it you learn a
lot sitting next to your old man the
movie so i would take him to a bunch of
movies i would show him
mine a bunch all the ones he missed and
[ __ ] maybe not all the ones he missed
you know what he'd watch them all [ __ ]
him and um
they're the one he'd love red state holy
[ __ ] he'd be like now this is what you
should have been doing from the
beginning i'd get a lecture and [ __ ]
like that but since he'd been dead for
like 19 years i would take that lecture
um where else would i take him i'd take
him to eat because the old man loved to
[ __ ] eat and [ __ ] you know um i
wouldn't take him
for a steak and cheese steak at morton's
that was what he had the night he died
so i'd go for some lighter affair
um you know he did die of a heart attack
um but we would go eat for sure maybe
i'd make him some hummus i doubt he
would like it
but
i know the one thing and i've told this
story before but uh i'll tell a
permutation of it um i i know for damn
skippy what i do when i was a kid i'm
talking about
maybe 11 or 12 10 11 12 in that corridor
let's just say 11 years old to be sure
yeah um
you know everyone was riding [ __ ]
dirt bikes
huffies and [ __ ] like that you know
bikes had been bikes at one point but
then huffy introduced a bike that looked
[ __ ] cool it was the bike that wore
sweat bands like it was just a cool ass
bike and had a middle [ __ ] bar in
case you went over it you put a padded
thing on it then there was a [ __ ] bar
here and [ __ ] which if you hit your nuts
on it hurt but somehow that was cool or
whatever the [ __ ] like they introduced
the bike that like if you have this bike
your life will be complete and naturally
i would have loved to have had one of
those bikes as opposed to the shitty old
bike that i had which had been passed
down and passed down and was probably
given to the family and [ __ ] like that
so
um
my father
for my [ __ ] birthday
was like he wants one of those bikes so
we're gonna get him one of those bikes
and i was so excited because i was like
oh yeah but we were poor uh my mom hates
when i say that so i'll say we were a
lower lower lower lower
lower uh middle class family and a you
know three kids
they're not all getting [ __ ] what
they want when they want it and a new
bike is expensive particularly when you
have a bike that works just fine like
this bike just looks cool big deal like
clothes look cool and you don't wear
those clothes so you'll be fine with
this bike and [ __ ] so
you know
when he my mom was like your dad's
getting you that bike i was like holy
[ __ ] and my dad spent a week in the
garage and i didn't know what he was
doing they kept the garage door closed
his big [ __ ] secret and [ __ ] and his
free time was precious because he worked
late at nights and stuff worked the
night shift at the post office
so you know him devoting any time to any
project was a [ __ ] big thing
and after a week on my birthday
i was presented they brought me outside
my mom and dad and i was like okay here
comes
and they opened the garage door and what
i saw was the saddest
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] bike i've ever
seen in my life it was my bike
but with some [ __ ] gussied up [ __ ]
like there was no middle bar
between my handlebars but he made one by
taking like this thin pipe and like
chicken wiring it between the handlebars
so it just moved and [ __ ] it wasn't
supportive or anything um you couldn't
put
a cool pad on the middle bar because the
middle bar was this gigantic [ __ ]
thing so he wrapped it in faux [ __ ]
leather um he put a
[ __ ] racing plate on it with the
number one on it he put streamers on the
handlebars you know it was a game effort
but it was like
bro this does not look like a [ __ ]
muffy bike what are you nuts and [ __ ]
but i was raised incredibly well
um
very empathetically by my mother um and
so naturally i never let on that i was
like are you [ __ ] kidding me i was
just like oh my god
thank you
this this is amazing thank you
and proceeded to probably never ride
that bike again such a bad move he took
my sister's barbie bike spray painted it
black and gave it to me
such a great brilliant move man dad game
is strong but i'll tell you right now
if i get a week with my dad or three
days with my dad
[ __ ] it i've said it before like i will
give you all the money i have
if i can ride that [ __ ] bike with him
just once now took a long [ __ ] time
when i was a kid that was a nightmare i
didn't want to be seen with that [ __ ]
bike now
smart enough to know how much love that
[ __ ] bike was made with nobody will
ever make a [ __ ] thing with for me in
this life except maybe my wife who had a
child but that was an accident so
a happy one but you know unplanned
no one in this life will ever make a
thing specifically for me
that was made with as much care
attention and affection and as much
creativity as that guy could muster with
the [ __ ] two nickels he had in his
pocket and [ __ ] young me of course
was like oh i couldn't be caught dead on
this [ __ ] bike but me now
i'd take that bike onto 101 [ __ ] like
[ __ ] i would ride that bike right
into the [ __ ] earth i would pay cash
money to have it refurbished every few
years and [ __ ] so that was like the
[ __ ] ship of thesis at the end of the
day you'd be like is it the real bike at
the end of the day or has he replaced
all the pieces and [ __ ] like i would
treat it like the treasure that it was
um
so yeah given a [ __ ] moment to go
back
given three days with dad
i would do that now my dad would be like
what do you mean you never liked that
bike
because he was oblivious right he was
like sleeping most of the day and
working at night so he never saw whether
i rode the bike or not so it never broke
his [ __ ] heart
but
yeah i would
i would do that excellent question give
it up for him ladies and gentlemen
you and dad go to the movies man
yeah we totally tagged that all right jc
all right that's a special bonus fourth
question
last question
brandon
burriso brandon get up here everyone
give it up for brandon
[Applause]
hello
brandon before you ask this question i
have one for you
do you live in los angeles
i do excellent then ask him the second
question i don't have a second question
do you like harry potter
yes i sure do excellent would you like
to go see harry potter and the deathly
hallows at the hollywood bowl on june
30th
with a score performed by a live
orchestra i sure would i have two
tickets for those i would like those
tickets no don't let this question suck
yeah your question has to be amazing
well my question is music related so so
it's on brand all right so those tickets
are getting a little closer to me even
better it's also related to elvis a
little oh [ __ ] [ __ ] back off i got
this
a little a little uh in honor of elvis
coming out this week i wanted to ask
what are some of your favorite needle
drops throughout film history
excellent [ __ ] question give it up
for that question that deserves the
tickets
[Applause]
um
needle drops or just music in general
let's go music in general music in
general making it too wide yeah well at
that point [ __ ] all of streets of
fire
like streets of fire is a movie that i
watch all the time and go like somebody
should remake this movie and then i'm
like no don't it's [ __ ] perfect and
[ __ ] somebody should just make another
movie like it somebody should make a
sequel should be us
yeah
um boulevards of flames
this is like streets of fire but bigger
wider
um
you got one i'm thinking i mean it's
it's i'm trying not to to go the easy
route which is anything in goodfellas or
anything in public [ __ ] yeah you know
because those guys are the kings of
needle drop yeah
and casino i remember seeing casino and
we were working at universal at that
point megan mall rats and so you know
they were making casino at that point
and so we had like [ __ ] privy to
inside details and [ __ ] and at the time
that was like hands down the most
expensive
[ __ ] soundtrack
of all time and he don't even use full
songs you want to talk about needle drop
sometimes he'll use 10 seconds of a very
expensive song and just move the [ __ ] on
man oh
you're right man the scorsese stuff and
the quentin terence
tino stuffer
brilliance needle trap
let's leave them off the table because
they're so good
yeah
so
[Laughter]
i guess we better put them back on the
table
[ __ ]
it is a great question in as much as
we're stumped
because you think it's an easy one where
you're like oh my god [ __ ] i can list
everything but i could really what i'm
what i'm thinking is i can list all the
needle drop moments in my movies because
like you know i edited the movie and
[ __ ] i'm so
dialed into them and stuff like that but
i'm not going to list my [ __ ] as
examples that's tacky however i will say
that in zach and miriam there's a
brilliant needle drop of uh the pixies
hey
which i still to this day i'm like all
right i'm a filmmaker that proves it
right there
um some people would be like no you're
not but i
i happen to think that i i am really
really excited for the uh the my chem
needle drop in clerks 3. it's it's
honestly the my kim
we use my chemical romance's uh welcome
to the black parade as the opening of
clerk's three and it is my finest hour
of needle drop the whole [ __ ] opening
in the movie was composed to the song
visually speaking and stuff and in terms
of it being executed on the day somehow
we mount wound up elevating so
for san diego for the comic con this
year by the time we go to comic con i do
my hall h panel uh the trailer will have
already been out and stuff for clerks
three but at my panel we're going to
show the opening five minutes of the
movie which is that entire [ __ ]
sequence and stuff so if you're going to
comic-con you got that to look forward
to all right i got one oh [ __ ] i was
stalling for you go ahead good job um
the reason why i like this one is not
just that the song is great which it is
and it's not just that the movie is good
which it is but it's it's used in this
moment in the movie
to conjure a very specific feeling
which is
youth
and kind of the daffiness of
carefree driving late at night with your
friends
and that feeling of a song that just
comes on the radio
that overtakes you body and soul and
you're you're moved to it this may be
the best needle drop of all time go
ahead it's it's bohemian rhapsody
absolutely yeah which
it's it's the only song for that moment
and it may be the reason that movie made
over 100 million dollars because when
you saw that clip yeah it's like you
said you're just like that's me i've
done that that's what it's like to be
[ __ ] 19 years old driving in the
middle of the town you grew up in with
nothing [ __ ] to do but be in this car
with your friends and then the song
comes on and you've never been any place
better you're where you're supposed to
be and there's just something about that
moment like i
the movie the rest of it is at this
point for me a little give or take like
it was hilarious when i was 19 but most
things were
and today looking back on it it is what
it was it's a relic of a bygone age um
but that sequence still [ __ ] bangs
because that song is just perfect um
excellent [ __ ] pull everything i had
give it up for mark that's fantastic
maybe like one of the greatest needle
drop moments is some people will point
to uh
almost famous when they did tiny dancer
on the bus uh that's lovely and stuff
but in terms of needle drop what was i
just thinking um [ __ ] i had one it was
god damn it
god i just had it all right jc filling
i'll remember probably not the best but
definitely fun was you could be mine in
terminator 2
just before schwarzenegger shows up you
realize he's a good guy and he pulls a
gun out of a box of roses yes for guns
and roses
see the one that i love even i mean
that's great but the you could be mine
drop in terminator salvation
for me is is maybe better because it's
about john connor remembering what it
was like to be young
and so even now as a grizzled [ __ ]
veteran of the robot uprising that dude
still remembers like i was a teenager at
a motorcycle once that's the song you
played when you have a motorcycle
um this is not deep well this is deep
cut so everyone probably won't identify
with it but there's a movie called
valley girl which i deeply deeply love
um one of my favorite movies of all time
and they expertly uh they martha
coolidge the director expertly used
um
um
uh i'll melt with you you know i'll stop
the world and with you they do a montage
of
of uh
randy and julie falling in love all over
los angeles all over hollywood in the
valley and it's
absolute perfection um it's the
for me personally as a filmmaker the
model for every montage i've ever
tried to do like it's a perfect
cinematic montage um another perfect
natal drop
i don't know if it's perfect but like it
works in as much as whenever i hear the
song i instantly go to a [ __ ] dugout
where i'm staring up at the ceiling as i
get [ __ ] by the [ __ ] stereo guy
fast times ridgemont high somebody's
baby like that [ __ ] song whatever
comes on i heard my kids singing it once
when she was 12 i was like oh no
um yeah but nothing is gonna be as good
as [ __ ] that you're absolutely right
man it's weird that more movies don't
try to imitate that
bohemian rhapsody moment
right now i'm going why didn't i do that
i have a good needle drop story okay
it's like real world so you mentioned
valley girl yeah
there's abandoned valley girl called the
plim souls i love them absolutely so
that needle drop is responsible for my
relationship
jen was which song uh oldest story in
the world
so she was listening to spotify
on her ipod
she lived in hollywood we hadn't talked
in five years and she was up on the
balcony of the chinese theater watching
the thor 2 premiere walk down the street
and it was raining and it was kind of
shitty out and she's like i just need a
guy
who will
sit in dirty hollywood with me and watch
silly hollywood stuff and five years
later she texted me that night while she
was listening to that song she texted me
the
spotify link and said just listen to
this song
isn't that crazy
did she did you guys know it was from
that movie
i did i mean she does she loves that
movie i was like
[ __ ] amazing i was like who the
[ __ ] texting me
what is this oh it's the rest of my life
yeah yeah but that text was it was it
was the beginning of everything that
came after [ __ ] oh man yeah like look
it it ain't gonna necessarily give you
the [ __ ] life that jay sees guys
happily mary's got a kid he's [ __ ] a
bar magazine not married yet let's
simmer down practically married and [ __ ]
common-law married at the very least but
valley girl is that good a movie where
you will get something out of it if you
watch it you'll get laid five years
later
finally
um that was a great question that was
that was a great answer you win the
[ __ ] tickets give it up for a man
enjoy thank you enjoy them deathly
hallows and we will have two other sets
of tickets to give away over the summer
the back to the future where the live
orchestra is going to be at the bowl and
then uh the john williams maestro at the
movies in uh in september i believe so
you have to come back if you're here you
got that chance um [ __ ] man it's uh
almost 11 o'clock at night we did it
this show just rolls like sometimes i'm
like oh it's gonna be a quick show
tonight we don't have a lot i never say
that it always just [ __ ] expands and
stuff um did you have a good time
tonight ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
we only get to do fun [ __ ] like this
because our friend owns a bar give it up
for banff man himself jc for prior to
scum and villainy cantina waiting for
you right here in hollywood and stuff uh
but there is no show ladies and
gentlemen we all know without the guy
sitting in my [ __ ]
left i always have to [ __ ] figure it
out left well i'm not like up there i
know normally i'm doing this [ __ ] the
guy to my left man give it up for
marvelous mark bernard
thank you
and that is fat man beyond for this week
man i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernard
tune in next time which by the way i
think we're going to be doing this from
the san diego comic con i know do you
have details not yet but there's going
to be a live show i think we go what
night is this thursday thursday night
our ticket's gonna go on sale
soon um we're doing shows at the movies
there the whole week and we're on
thursday but we're also streaming fat
man
thursday
friday and saturday like updates but
friday before you go to the right
friday yeah yeah yeah because he's up
for an award this year anyway yes
um so yes uh fat man's gonna be
happening all over comic con so if
you're going to comic con or even you're
just watching comic con from youtube
you'll we'll be giving you updates on
the daily and stuff uh but anyway back
to the closing the show that is fat man
beyond for this week tune in next time
same
fat time same fat channel spodcast.com
or youtube.com kevin smith jeff's kiss
[ __ ]
[Applause]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens when jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith